Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Das Chaos Radio in Blumen auf Fritz ist eine streitbare Sendung. Am häufigsten wird darüber gestritten, ob während der Sendung Musik gespielt werden soll oder nicht und ob dieser elend lange Open-Hits wirklich sein muss oder nicht. Aber er muss natürlich sein, weil Kraftwerk gehört zum Chaos Radio so wie Computer. Außerdem brauchen wir mindestens immer noch zehn Minuten, um unseren ganzen Rechner hier an den Start zu bringen, Internet einzurichten und was nicht alles. In Wirklichkeit gilt sich Frank Rosengard vom Chaos Computer Club, der hier ist dann noch mal heimlich die Haare, damit dein Radio auch wirklich gut aussieht. Außerdem ist heute noch Nico Longolius dabei. Schnee von Morgen war es, oder?
Ja, ich freue mich sehr, hier zu sein.
Schnee von Morgen ist die Firma. Jetzt noch mal ganz von vorne Chaos Radio heute. Das ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Das heißt, die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club haben sich ein Thema herausgesucht, über das sie mit euch reden wollen. Einerseits, um es euch mal ein bisschen näher zu bringen, weil es wie immer ein Thema ist, was euch alle irgendwie betrifft. Also man weiß es nicht so direkt, das findet im Hintergrund statt. Und andererseits weiß natürlich, wie es so schöne Risiken und Nebenwirkungen gibt. Und das sind die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club Großteren, die auch aufzudecken. Heute geht es um Cloud Computing. Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, Moment mal, Cloud Computing, Wiki zur Sendung, ah, das hatte ich noch vergessen. Es gibt ein Wiki zur Sendung, es gibt einen Blog zur Sendung, es gibt einen Chat zur Sendung. Die Links dort sind alle auf fritz.de, dort könnt ihr euch einfach hinklicken. Und dann gibt es die Links zu allen Dingen, die ihr machen könnt, während der Sendung. Wir gucken auch ab und zu drauf. Aber am allerliebsten wäre es natürlich, wenn ihr anruft, 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer, um von euren Erfahrungen mit Cloud Computing zu erzählen und den Sorgen, die ihr damit möglicherweise habt. Oder ob ihr sagt, Cloud Computing, das ist doch super. Aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal klären, was ist überhaupt Cloud Computing? Also eigentlich sind wir fast ein bisschen später an. Wir versuchen ja sonst immer so Themen am Zukunftsweisen oder in die Zukunft schauen zu behandeln. Dieser ganze Cloud Hype ist jetzt eigentlich mindestens schon zwei Jahre alt. Das gibt uns jetzt aber die Möglichkeit, mal so ein bisschen rückschauend auch zu gucken, was ist jetzt eigentlich wirklich noch übrig von diesem Hype? Ist es wirklich ein Hype? Ist es der große Bringer oder nicht? Und vor allem, welche Probleme haben sich in der Praxis auch auskristallisiert damit? Aber was ist denn überhaupt? Was ist es? Ja, die Cloud ist vielleicht... Nico, erzähl doch mal diese komische, diese Anekdote mit dieser Internetwolke.
Also ich kenne die Begriffsdefinition immer so. Mir wird es immer so wie folgt nahegelegt, dass in IT-Powerpoint-Präsentationen immer ein Symbol auftaucht und das eine Wolke. Offensichtlich ist die im Powerpoint immer ganz schnell zu finden. Und diese Wolke wurde in Powerpoint-Präsentationen immer dann verwendet, wenn Themen dargestellt werden sollten, die eigentlich zu komplex wurden. Und wenn man sagte, das ist irgendwie so die Cloud, die Wolke. Früher hätte man vielleicht Blackbox oder so was Ähnliches dazu gesagt. Und in dieser Wolke haben sich immer solche Sachen wie das Internet befunden oder die Server-Farm oder das Lärm der Apache-Web-Server und die Datenbank. Und deshalb war die Wolke von jeher so ein ganz diffuses, ominöser Begriff für Dinge, die im Internet geschehen.
Also quasi der Techniker hat seinem Chef erklärt, pass auf Chef, wir brauchen da ein bisschen Rechenkraft. Also quasi was man auf dem Computer kennt. Das muss aber ein bisschen mehr sein. Wir müssen jetzt aber nicht genau erklären. Ich habe mal hier diese Wolke dahin gemalt, damit du dann sozusagen, da musst du Geld reinwerfen. Da kommt dann irgendwie Rechenzeug raus.
Anstelle einer Erklärung male ich eine Wolke.
Okay, wir wollen es jetzt aber trotzdem ein bisschen genauer wissen. Was genau ist denn jetzt Cloud Computing? Also ich versuche es ein bisschen so einzugrenzen, dass ich sage, dass Cloud Computing oder diese Cloud-Dienste eigentlich die Sachen sind, die früher von vielleicht drei Jahren noch eher Sachen sind, die bei mir auf meinem Computer gelaufen sind, also auf meinem Desktop-Computer, auf meinem Laptop. Oder vielleicht auch, wenn ich jetzt einen Service habe, also eine Firma bin, die in meinem Rechenzentrum, im Keller des Hauses, des Bürohauses gelaufen sind oder irgendwo bei einem Provider bestanden. Aber so klassische Sachen, die ziemlich sicher, oder wo ich ziemlich sicher weiß, auf genau welchem Computer die gelaufen sind. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt irgendwas schiefgelaufen ist, dann drücke ich da irgendwie schnell den Ausschalter oder ziehe den Stecker, dann ist dieser Dienst weg. Oder andersherum, wenn mir irgendwie aus dem Keller der Server geklaut wird, dann ist halt auch dieser Dienst weg. So und es gibt also einen ziemlich bestimmten Ort, wo diese ganze Sache läuft und es ist klar definiert. Allerdings natürlich auch mit dem Nachteil, dass wenn der Server im Keller komplett ausgelastet ist und am Anschlag läuft, dann ist er eben auch am Anschlag, dann kann er nicht mehr machen. Und wenn ich mehr Kapazität brauche, mehr Rechenkapazität, dann muss ich einfach noch einen zweiten Server dazustellen. Und wenn ich dann aber noch zwei Wochen feststelle, gut, das war jetzt nur vorübergehend mal, weil ich irgendwie eine große Werbeaktion gemacht habe, dann langweilen diese zwei Server eigentlich wieder. Und da ist eigentlich auch das, wo für zumindest im kommerziellen Bereich die Vorteile für so Cloud-Dienste liegen.
Vielleicht noch einmal, um so einen alternativen Ansatz zu wählen. Ich glaube halt, dass dieses Cloud Computing gar nicht so was furchtbar neues, sondern was ganz Altes ist, weil in der Anfangszeit der Computer waren Terminal-Systeme total innen. Terminal-Systeme bedeutet, dass mein Computer, an dem ich saß, eigentlich nicht mehr war als eine Tastatur und einen Bildschirm und die eigentlich rechten Leistung an einem zentralen Ort abgerufen wurde. Das hat sich alles geändert und in der Zwischenzeit ist es halt im Mode gekommen, dass alle Leute bei sich zu Hause die Hölle in Tüten als Computer haben. Also einfach Computer, die haben zwei DVD-Brenner und einen Wahnsinns-Vierkern, CPU und Arbeitsspeicher. Also das Geräte...
Woher weißt du, was ich für ein Rechner zu Hause stehen habe?
Geräte, die einfach alles können. Und heute geht dieser Trend wieder in die Gegenrichtung. Also ich glaube, man muss dieses Cloud Computing gegenüber ganz vielen Sachen abgrenzen. Aber an dieser einen Stelle geht es in die Gegenrichtung, dass halt diese Terminal-Dienste wieder entwerfen, dass die Computer wieder kleiner werden. Das Innenwort ist, glaube ich, Netbox.
Oder FinKline, also dünner, kleiner. Ab heute Abend auch iPad. Ab heute Abend auch iPad. Hast du auch schon Schweiß unter den Achseln gehabt heute Abend? Die Erwartung auf die Verkündung wartend. Wir können vielleicht am Ende der Sendung da noch ein bisschen drüber herziehen. Jetzt bleiben wir erstmal im Cloud Computing. Also, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist es sozusagen die wichtigste Unterschiede zum Cloud Computing, zum Nicht-Cloud Computing, ist, man hat nicht mehr selber den Rechner irgendwo stehen, sondern die Rechenkraft steht irgendwo.
Man weiß nicht mehr, was man hat.
Aber man weiß es gar nicht mehr. Also sagen, das ist auch der Unterschied zum normalen Webhosting. Also wenn ich jetzt hingehe und ich kauf mir halt irgendwie einen Server bei einem Webhoster, wo ich gerne meine Webpräsenz betreiben möchte, dann weiß ich auch zumindest ziemlich genau, wo der steht. Das ist dann auch noch nicht Cloud Computing, sondern Cloud Computing ist es erst, wenn ich zu einem Anbieter gehe und sage, Anbieter, gib mir einfach mal Rechenkraft in Höhe von, wie misst man das dann, in Höhe von zwei Maschinen oder in Höhe von?
Es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze, das zu messen. Amazon geht so einen Weg, dass sie eine Compute Unit definieren. Das heißt, sie sagen einem gar nicht mehr zu, du hast einen eigenen Prozessor oder einen Kern eines Prozessors, sondern wir definieren eine neue Einheit, die heißt Compute Unit, die kann ungefähr so viel und davon kannst du dir anteilig welche kaufen.
Und das kostet dann wie viel? Also kannst du dann ein Beispiel?
Also der kleinste Server, den man sich bei Amazon Web Services mieten kann, aber es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Anbieter in dem Markt, kostet 10 US Dollar Cent in der Stunde.
Also ich kann mir sozusagen einen abstrakten Rechner mieten, es kostet mich 10 Cent die Stunde.
Genau, das sind glaube ich so 7 Euro Cent.
Um das mal ein bisschen praktischer zu machen, was genau machst du damit? Also Schnee von morgens, deine Firma, du mietest, hast du erzählt, manchmal für wenige Tage hunderte von diesen virtuellen Rechnern, warum?
Genau, wir haben eine Firma, die WebTV-Lösungen baut. Also wir haben ganz viel mit Filmen im Internet zu tun. Und ein klassisches Anforderungsszenario an uns ist, dass irgendjemand ein Archiv hat, in dem befinden sich vielleicht 2500 Filme. Und diese sollen jetzt Internet-fertig gemacht werden. Und Internet-fertig, weil das Internet halt so ein ominöser Raum ist, bedeutet halt nicht mehr ein Format, sondern es bedeutet halt so was wie fünf Videoformate, weil man will eine hohe Qualität für Flash-Streaming haben und eine niedrige und man möchte auf den iPhones gesehen werden können. Man möchte aber auch auf anderen Mobiltelefonen gesehen werden können. Man will vielleicht noch eine MPEG-2-Version. Und am Ende hat man ganz viele verschiedene Videoversionen, die man aus diesem einen Ausgangsvideo machen muss. Und das ist sehr, sehr rechenintensiv. Also wenn man das bei seinem Computer zu Hause machen wollen würde, würde dieser mehrere Jahre daran rechnen. Und unser erster Use-Case ist einfach, dass wir zu Amazon gehen und sagen, Mensch Jungs, wir hätten jetzt gerne mal 500 Computer für eine Stunde. Und die sollen sich einfach auf unsere Filme drauf stürzen und die sollen denen diese ganzen Formate wandeln. Und dann kriegen wir von denen eine Antwort und sagen, 500 Computer ist kein Problem. Dann starten 500 Computer für uns. Das dauert ungefähr zwei Minuten, bis die an sind. Das ist im Übrigen ein Gefühl von Macht. Genau. Und dann machen die sich an die Arbeit und rechnen diese Videos in einer Windeseile durch und legen sich danach wieder schlafen, womit wir quasi den ersten tollen Use-Case haben. Diese 500 Computer sind in dieser einen Stunde vielleicht gar nicht so fürchterlich billig. Aber die anderen 1000 Stunden brauch ich die ja gar nicht.
Das heißt, du hast sie tatsächlich nur für diese Zeit gekauft, wo du sie wirklich, wirklich, wirklich benutzt. Die Frage, die ich mir jetzt stelle, ist sozusagen, das Vorteil, einen eigenen Server oder einen eigenen Rechner zu haben, ist ja, dass die eigene Software da schon drauf läuft. Ist es jetzt so bei Cloud Computing, dass man quasi gleich die Art und Weise, also du musst Videos umwandeln, ist die dazu benötigte Software dann gleich schon vorhanden? Sonst müsstest du ja quasi, also die Horrorverstellung, die ich gerade habe, okay, 500 Rechner möglicherweise unter Windows, die kriegst du doch in einer Stunde gar nicht mal installiert. Wie funktioniert das? Das funktioniert so, dass du einen installierst, ein Beispiel, ein Muster, man macht sich da ein sogenanntes Image. Und wenn du es schaffst, deine Anwendung so zu bauen, dass sie wirklich 500 Mal mit 500 identischen Rechnern funktioniert, also weil sie wirklich 500 Mal eigentlich auch genau das gleiche macht, dann ist es in Ordnung. Was halt wirklich ein echter Schmerz ist, gerade bei Windows das einmal einzurichten, weil du musst tatsächlich dann auch übers Netz das ganze Ding bedienen. Das heißt, Windows lässt sich ja bekanntlich eigentlich nur mit der Maus vernünftig bedienen. Das heißt, du musst also auch die ganzen Mausbewegungen einmal durchs Internet machen nach Amerika. Das heißt, du hast irgendwie so 200 Millisekunden Verzögerung immer auf dem Weg. Das heißt, das ist alles wirklich elend, zäh und lahm, das alles zu machen. Aber wenn du es dann erstmal hast, dann kannst du dir dieses System praktisch einfrieren und dann in beliebiger Form klonen. Also besser dann auch, sagen, jedes Mal die zwei Minuten ist das eingefrorene System wird wieder an Start gebracht.
Genau. Also vielleicht, um noch ein anderes Beispiel zu bringen, das, was die Zuhörer vielleicht kennen, es gab lange Zeit, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das heute noch gibt, das SETI-Projekt, wo man selber auf seinem Computer eine Software installieren konnte, um nach außerirdischen Lebensformen zu suchen. Das, also ich kann es gerade nicht mehr sagen.
Man hatte da irgendwelche Radarsignale einfach, also man hat im Prinzip Rauschen empfangen, also aus dem Radar, man hatte eine riesengroße Antenne gehabt, hat die ins Weltall gerichtet und da kam im Wesentlichen Rauschen raus. Und was diese Clients oder diese Recheneinheiten dann gemacht haben, ist versucht, irgendwie anhand von irgendwelchen mathematischen Filter-Algorithmen versucht, ob da nicht auch irgendwas drin ist, was nicht rauschend ist.
Es war eine Weile lang total innen, einen SETI-Client laufen zu haben und den auch auf Servern laufen zu haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wovon du redest.
Es gab auch Statistiken, während der letzten Woche die meiste Rechenzeit aufgebracht hat und es war toll, in dieser Statistik weit oben zu stehen. Und das ist quasi Cloud Computing andersrum. Also die haben das System ja auch nur umgedreht und haben gesagt, wir brauchen ganz viel Rechenpower. Uns ist in dem Fall konkret, es ist gar nicht zeitkritisch. Also das heißt, wann dieser Datenhatten berechnet wird, ist nicht wichtig. Wir würden nur gerne, dass sie alle berechnet wollen. Und es hat sich quasi eine Cloud der User gebildet, die gesagt haben, ihr dürft auf meinem Rechner einen Teil meiner Rechenleistung dafür nutzen, um euren in dem Fall wahrscheinlich Quatsch zu berechnen.
Ich muss jetzt kurz einhaken, es gibt ja sozusagen auch ein Chat zur Sendung, da wird gerade gesagt, das CETI wäre nicht so interessant gewesen, weil nicht so nützlich, aber Folding at Home wäre ein schönes Beispiel gewesen. Da geht es um Krebs im Chemikalien oder Bio-Berechnung, Krebs gegen Mittel herausfinden, so ein verteiltes Rechenprojekt.
Auch eine ganz CPU-intensive Sache. Es ist wahnsinnig schwierig, ein dreidimensionales Bild eines Eiweiß-Moleküls zu berechnen. Ich glaube, es geht in dem Fall konkret darum. Man muss aber eine Vorstellung davon haben, wie diese Moleküle im Raum aussehen, damit man schätzen kann, was für Wirkungen die haben werden. Und das ist so wahnsinnig rechenintensiv, dass man eben sehr, sehr viel CPU-Power dafür braucht. Und diese CPU-Power kann auch von der Community zur Verfügung gestellt werden und hilft dann eben bei der Erforschung Medikamente.
Es ist ja so, bei diesen Erforschungen, wo die Community mithilft, ist es so, da sind halt immer irgendwelche Rechner an. Bei dem Beispiel, was du erzählt hast, da mietest du dir ja einmal einen Tag lang irgendwie für eine gewisse Zeitdauer diese 500 Rechner und machst sie dann aber gleich wieder aus. Gibt es denn auch Cloud-Anwendungen, die quasi ständig läuft, wo man das so mal größer, mal kleiner skaliert, je nachdem, wie man es braucht?
Ja, also wir versuchen das Feld ja jetzt mal so ein bisschen erschöpfend zu erschlagen. Also ich glaube, aus Sicht der Macintosh User ist der bekannteste Cloud-Dienst MobileMe. Das ist inzwischen auf jedem Computer mit drauf. Bedeutet, aus Sicht des Macintosh Users, ich kann diesen MobileMe-Account aktivieren. Das kostet ein bisschen Geld, ich weiß nicht wie viel. Zu viel. Zu viel. Und bekomme dafür von Steve Jobs persönlich eine...
Der kommt ins Zimmer und schüttelt dir die Hand und sagt, jetzt kannst du deine Daten immer zu MobileMe hochladen.
Ihr müsst mir ein bisschen helfen, weil ich selber tatsächlich auch nicht nutze, aber ich glaube der Dienst umfasst A, dass man so eine Art virtuelle Festplatte im Internet bekommt, also ein Ort, wo man Daten abspeichern kann, plus ein Dienst, der die eigenen Daten mit mobilen Endgeräten synchronisiert.
Oder mit anderen Rechnern, wo auch MobileMe draufläuft.
Genau. Und gibt es noch was?
Nichts, was funktionieren würde. Das ist eigentlich schon der zweite Aspekt von diesem ganzen Thema. Nämlich das, was für den normalen Nutzer, für den Endnutzer einfach an Cloud-Diensten zur Verfügung steht. Also die Sachen, die davon leben, dass sie verteilt im Netz sind. Und die Idee ist, dass wirklich ich nun ein ganz, ganz schmales, kleines Gerät habe mit einer kleinen Festplatte. Und auch gar nicht so viel CPU-Power, sondern eigentlich mehr so ein Darstellungsgerät. Und dann möglichst viel Anwendung in die Cloud-Verlagere. Das heißt also auch so Dienste wie eine Textverarbeitung, zum Beispiel von Google hat eine Textverarbeitung angeboten, die gar nicht mehr auf meinem Rechner läuft, sondern die läuft zwar schon noch in einem Browser auf meinem Rechner, aber insgesamt ist es eine Software, die eigentlich von Google zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Und das sind so, da gibt es so verschiedene Sachen und wahrscheinlich, wie Nico schon gesagt hat, das Klassischste ist diese Online-Backup-Variante, also wo ich dann im Netz speicher, wo ich dann im Netz Speicher habe und da einfach Sachen hinschiebe. So, das ist natürlich auch gleichzeitig, sag ich mal, die kritischste von allen Anwendungen, weil das heißt natürlich, dass meine Daten, die ich sonst auf meiner Festplatte ganz privat habe, die dann natürlich auch im Netz liegen. Und gerade auch der Mobile-Me-Dienst ist jetzt auch der, der da auch am wenigsten gut von sich reden gemacht hat oder der nicht besonders gut von sich reden gemacht hat, was jetzt die Sicherheit und Verschlüsselung angeht. Das ist aber eine Sache, da werden wir später nochmal zu kommen, welche Gefahren da eigentlich bestehen. Jetzt haben wir also Speicherplatz und jetzt haben wir Anwendungen, die man sich sozusagen selber bucht. Was ist denn jetzt im Twitter, Facebook, die ganzen Sachen, das hat doch auch irgendwie was mit der Cloud zu tun?
Also der Oberbegriff dafür ist sicherlich Software-Assist-Service im weitesten Sinne. Also während wir am Anfang diesen Begriff der Terminal-Systeme hatten, also dass ich nur noch einen Bildschirm und eine Tastatur habe und einen kompletten Computerfernsteuer, waren wir in der Mitte ja jetzt ganz kurz angeschliffen bei Storage, also Speicherdiensten, einfach Menschen, die mir eine Festplatte im Internet anbieten, wo ich große Dateien ablegen kann oder kleine oder was auch immer. Und jetzt am Ende waren wir wo, Entschuldige?
Bei solchen Diensten wie Twitter.
Software as a Service. Also das bedeutet Leute, die einfach für mich eine Anwendung virtualisieren. Also das bessere Beispiel war sicherlich die Google Documents. Gibt es inzwischen auch von Microsoft, die sowas mit anbieten. Und ich wollte als Konkurrenz ITA petten, aber die sind von Google gekauft worden. Also man kommt irgendwie um die nicht drunter. Also das heißt Anwendungen, die davor bei mir lokal auf meinem Rechner stattgefunden haben, finden auf einmal im Internet statt. Textverarbeitung, Tabellenkalkulationen und so weiter und so fort. Bei solchen Diensten wie Twitter, Facebook sieht die Sache etwas komplizierter aus. Die Infrastruktur, die diese Leute betreiben, ist ganz klar Cloud Computing. Also Facebook und Twitter laufen in Cloud Computing-Diensten. Ob die aus Sicht des Users jetzt Cloud Computing sind oder nicht, ist etwas schwer zu sagen, weil die Dienste selbst ja ohne das Internet gar keinen Sinn machen. Also das heißt, es gibt kein lokales Twitter.
Ja, aber wir wollen ja heute noch über Risiken und Nebenwirkungen sprechen. Das wäre ja auch wichtig, weil es ist schon so, wenn ihr nachher noch die Risiken erzählt, dann sind nicht nur die Dienste betroffen, die ich mir selber haben kann. Also ich habe meine Online-Festplatte irgendwo, sondern auch ich benutze einen Portal, einen Netzwerk, einen wie auch immer gearteten Dienst, der auf Cloud Computing basiert. Das heißt, ich kann auch da dann betroffen werden von diesen Risiken.
Genau, also es ist einfach ein Irrglaube, dass diese Cloud einfach nicht kaputt geht.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, weil man hört es immer so, ja ganz viele Rechner und virtuell und das wird alles hin und her geschoben. Das ist ja meine Idee so, okay, der Vorteil ist, irgendjemand anderes kümmert sich die ganze Zeit um die Hardware und ich kann sozusagen die Füße hochlegen, muss nur noch darum kümmern, dass meine Software irgendwie funktioniert. Das heißt, da kann nichts mehr kaputt gehen, weil wenn den Rechner kaputt geht, schieben die einfach den virtuellen Rechner woanders hin. Also theoretisch ist es natürlich so, dass wenn, ich habe halt einfach so ein Image nennt sich das, also ein Image ist ein vorbereitetes Betriebssystem. Das heißt, ich habe einfach eine große Datei, die auch gerne mal irgendwie 5 Gigabyte, 10 Gigabyte oder so was haben kann, wo aber einfach eine komplette, was eigentlich eine Kopie ist von meiner Festplatte. Also es wäre auch denkbar, dass ich auf meinem Rechner von meinem toll funktionierenden System, was ich da habe, von meinem Laptop auch einfach eine Kopie mache als Image. Das heißt also ich mache wirklich eine 1 zu 1 Kopie von meiner Festplatte und lade die zu so einem Cloud-Service hoch und würde das da laufen lassen. Das wäre theoretisch denkbar und dann hätte ich einen Klon von meinem Laptop oder von meinem Arbeitsplatzrechner auch in dieser Cloud zu laufen und könnte die dann auch entsprechend übers Netz bedienen. Das wäre schon durchaus auch denkbar. Was wollte ich sagen? Genau, also in der Theorie... Frag doch mal die Cloud. Ja, also in der Theorie ist es natürlich so, dass ich das Ding dann... Ich kann es zu Amazon geben, ich kann es zu GoGrid geben, ich kann es zu Anbieter ABC geben und kann sagen, da irgendwie fahrt einfach mein Image und dann ist es mir natürlich schon egal, wenn jetzt irgendwie einer von denen hat jetzt irgendwie ein Feuer im Rechenzentrum oder sowas und den brennt halt mal alles ab, dann gehe ich halt zum nächsten Anbieter. Das ist in der Theorie... Warte mal, das heißt aber schon, ich dachte in dem Moment, wo ich zu einem Anbieter gehe, der Cloud Computer macht, dann ist schon alles super. Naja, es kommt natürlich darauf an, wie verteilt der denn wieder ist. Also wahrscheinlich, wenn jetzt ein Google Cloud Dienste anbieten würde, die haben keine Ahnung, wie 100 Rechenzentren auf der Erde verteilt und das wäre dann wahrscheinlich nicht so schlimm, wenn da irgendwie drei von wegfallen oder sowas. Aber wenn jetzt ein Anbieter nur ein, zwei Rechenzentren hat und da ist halt einmal ein großer Stromausfall, dann fehlt denen schon mal 50 Prozent ihrer Kapazität. Also Sicherheit ist sozusagen nicht wirklich ein Zugewinn. Da kann es halt immer passieren, dass auch da noch was wegkommt. Also der Vorteil ist erstmal, ich kann eine Rechenleistung mieten, wann ich sie brauche und muss halt nicht mehr, also muss halt sagen, nicht den Überfluss zahlen. Gibt es da irgendwie Probleme, weil so wie das jetzt rausgekommen ist, eine große Firma hat eine ganze Anzahl von Computern und vermietet da die Rechenzeit. Wenn ich mir das vorstelle, wie man das mit dem Flugzeug macht, da verkauft man immer mehr Plätze, als das Flugzeug überhaupt hat, weil man rechnet damit, naja, die kommen sowieso nicht alle. Und dann passiert es aber manchmal doch, gibt es das beim Cloud Computing auch, also die sagen ich, Cloud Computing, also die verkaufen so viel Rechenkraft, dass quasi im Prinzip ihre Maschinen 120%ig ausgelastet werden. Und wenn dann wirklich tatsächlich mal alle Leute alles in Anspruch nehmen, was sie gekauft haben, dann sieht es finster aus.
Also vielleicht um noch ein Stück zurückzuspulen, einmal die Frage zu stellen, was ist eigentlich das Interesse der Cloud-Anbieter? Warum machen die das? Also dann versteht man sozusagen auch den Buchungs-Algorithmus. Also die Anbieter von Cloud Computing sind eigentlich alles Leute, die davor auch schon große IT-Infrastrukturen betrieben haben. Also es geht dabei um Google, Amazon, IBM, Adobe, Microsoft. Also es sind sowieso die großen Player, Apple. Und das sind Leute, die haben sowieso auf der ganzen Welt Rechenzentren und die haben sowieso eine Höllenstromrechnung und die haben sowieso das alles schon vor Ort. Und sie haben meistens ein Problem, das ist nämlich, dass ihre eigene Netznutzung nicht kontinuierlich ist, sondern wellenförmig. Sie produzieren selber einfach Peaks. Bei Amazon kann man sich vorstellen, die Harry Potter gibt es nicht mehr, das ist immer mein Beispiel. Sie verkaufen einmal im Jahr den neuen Harry Potter.
Die neue Twilight-DVD.
Genau. Und bei Microsoft kann man es sich irgendwie auch vorstellen, die haben halt hohe Serverlast, wenn der neue Patch rauskommt, also viermal am Tag.
Du meinst den von Internet Explorer, der ja sozusagen jetzt ganz offen war für viele Jahre?
Also so hat jeder sein eigenes Anforderungs-Szenario, was eine sehr peaklastige Anforderung auf die Server produziert. Das bedeutet, deren teure Investitionen langweilen sich die meiste Zeit über. Und jetzt gibt es zwei Strategien. Die erste ist, das so weit herunterzufahren, wie es irgendwie nur geht und zu sagen, wir behalten unsere eigene Infrastruktur, aber wir versuchen, das auf das Minimum zu begrenzen. Die zweite Taktik, und das ist das, was diese Player gerade machen, ist zu sagen, wir legen noch einen Schipper drauf, wir kaufen noch mehr Rechner, aber wir vermieten die Kapazitäten, die wir gerade nicht benötigen. Und wir versuchen eben mit dieser Mischkalkulation, also eben im Prinzip das, was du gerade versucht hast zu schildern, dass eben ein Hotel oder ein Flugzeug auch überbucht werden kann, weil die Veranstalter eben wissen, dass fünf Prozent der Reisenden den Flug vorher noch absagen oder fünf Prozent der Reisenden das Hotel vorher kündigen. Solche ähnlichen Szenarien gelten natürlich auch für die Cloud. Das heißt eben, wenn am Mittwochabend alle Leute auf der Welt versuchen, ihre Filmsammlung durchzurechnen, dann sehen wir natürlich alt aus. Das heißt, es ist möglich, eine Cloud-Over zu subscriben, also zu viel zu verkaufen. Aber das Szenario eben genau, dass wir ja in einer globalisierten Welt leben und eben das Anforderungsprofil nicht mehr die klassischen USA-Peaks erzeugt, also das morgens um neun USA-Zeit, sondern eben inzwischen kann ich ja auch als deutscher...
Du meinst, wenn die Zeit kommt, wo immer alle Leute an den Computer gehen?
Genau. In Deutschland ist es natürlich so, eine Seite wie Spiegel Online, die hat irgendwie morgens um neun einmal einen hohen Peak und dann hat sie irgendwie noch einen zur Mittagspause. Das heißt, das ist ja aber nicht typisch weltweit gesehen. Diese beiden Peaks sind sehr speziell für Spiegel Online und für diese geografische Lage. Und deshalb macht es Sinn, mehrere Player zusammen auf eine Infrastruktur zu werfen und eine Mischkalkulation aufzumachen.
Also ich fasse mal zusammen. Es ist so, Cloud Computing wird gemacht von Leuten, die eh schon extrem viele Rechner rumstehen haben, die bei denen natürlich den größten Teil der Zeit rumeideln, also einfach sozusagen nichts machen. Dann denken die sich, okay, wir vermieten es einfach. Und zwar an jeden, der irgendwie ein bisschen Rechenkraft will. Da gibt es ein Rechensystem, wo man sagt, okay, wir vermieten euch jetzt so eine Art abstrakten Rechner. Das heißt, nicht eine konkrete Maschine, sondern ein bisschen Rechenkraft. Im Prinzip so ein, also Frank hat es in der Ankündigung so schön geschrieben, ein digitaler Leiharbeiter. Und damit könnte es natürlich auch Probleme geben, wenn man zum Beispiel zu viele Leiharbeiter verkauft. Oder was ihr auch erzählt habt, ist, man kann 500 auf einmal anstellen, da läuft dann aber überall dasselbe System. Wenn das System jetzt einen Fehler hat, stelle ich mir vor, dann habe ich ja quasi, wenn ich das hacke, 500 Systeme gleich unter meiner Kontrolle. Das sind alles sehr interessante Fragen. Die werden wir allerdings nach den Nachrichten genauer in Angriff nehmen. Vorher hören wir noch ein Stückchen Musik, dann wie gesagt Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und dann geht es weiter hier im Chaos Radio in Blumen.
Ich bin gespannt, ihr da noch zu sehen habt.
Pielo ist das Dance or Die Trying im Chaosradio in Blumenau, Fritz. Die Playlist zu der Musik, die wir hier bei der Sendung spielen, die gibt's im Wiki zur Sendung ohne Link. Dazu gibt es auf fritz.de. Wir machen jetzt erst mal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht's weiter mit Cloud Computing.
Es gibt eine Nacht, die ist so einmalig, dass man sie immer und immer und immer wieder wieder erleben will.
Ach ja?
Was soll denn das für eine Nacht sein?
Da wird gejubelt, geklatscht, gewut und gefeiert. Und das ist so unbeschreiblich, dass man es eigentlich nicht beschreiben kann.
Am besten einfach selbst erleben. Äh, Moment mal.
Ich kaufe doch nicht die Katze im Sack. Mit einem wilden Mix musikalischer und wortgewandter Talente, die noch so unentdeckt sind, dass sie unbedingt entdeckt werden wollen. Und was? Es entscheidet die härteste Jury der Welt. Das Publikum. Also ihr.
Hart, aber unfair.
Die Fritz Nacht der Talente. Nächste Termine.
Samstag, 13.
März.
Und Samstag, 15.
Mai.
Im Großen Saal vom Admiralspalast Berlin. Und solange es doch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten geht.
Zum Beispiel auch auf fritz.de.
Die Fritz Nacht der Talente.
Immer einmalig, immer unbeschreiblich und immerhin die beste Katze im Sack, wo gibt.
Und das hört man.
Um kurz nach halb zwölf. Nachricht. Mit Marzine Schneider.
Soziale Netzwerke wie Facebook oder StudiVZ sollen noch sicherer werden. Das Bundesverbraucherministerium fordert von den Anbietern, dass Daten von vornherein geblockt werden, damit nicht erst die Nutzer aktiv werden müssen. Außerdem sollten nach Meinung des Ministeriums Inhalte der Netzwerke komplett wieder gelöscht werden können. Mehrere soziale Netzwerke hatten im letzten Jahr auf eine Abmahnung der Verbraucherzentralen reagiert und versprochen, mehr für den Datenschutz zu tun. Die internationale Gemeinschaft will den Jemen stärker wirtschaftlich und politisch helfen. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Konferenz in London, an der Vertreter von rund 20 Staaten und Organisatoren wie der Weltbank teilnahmen. Nach Angaben des britischen Außenministers Milliband wurde ein 5-Punkte-Plan vereinbart. Er sieht unter anderem Hilfen bei der Grenzsicherung des Jemen und eine Unterstützung durch den Währungsfonds IWF vor. US-Ausministerin Clinton betonte, ein instabiler Jemen sei eine Gefahr für die ganze Region. Das verarmte Land gilt als Rückzugsgebiet für Mitglieder des Terrornetzwerkes Al-Qaeda. Das Internet spielt in vielen Unternehmen inzwischen eine wichtige Rolle bei der Personalauswahl. Mehr als die Hälfte der Chefs sucht Online-Infos über Bewerber, das berichtet der Softwarehersteller Microsoft. 16 Prozent haben danach schon Kandidaten abgelehnt. Ausschlaggebend waren zum Beispiel Kommentare, Fotos oder Videos des Bewerbers im Internet. Fußball-Zweitligges Union Berlin muss in den nächsten Spielen auf Abwehrspieler Daniel Schulz verzichten. Er hat sich gestern beim Training den Mittelfinger gebrochen und fällt bis zu zehn Wochen aus. Union-Sportdirektor Beek sagte, die neue Verletzung sei bitter für Schulz, weil er vorher schon lange Knie-Probleme gehabt habe. In Potsdam, Frankfurt, Cottbus, Neuropin und Angermünde haben wir minus 5 Grad, in Wittenberge sind es minus zwei und in Berlin um die minus fünf Grad. Nachts ist es stark bewölkt und zwei bis acht Zentimeter Neuschnee rieseln auf euch nieder. Die Temperatur klettert noch runter bis auf minus sieben Grad. Morgen gibt es dann ab und zu Schnee oder Graubeschauer. Es wird etwas wärmer als heute und das Ganze bei knapp über Null Grad. A10, westlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreig Haveland. Zwischen Spanda und Brieselang besteht Gefahr durch eine ungesicherte Unfallstelle. Hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. A11, Berlin Richtung Pormellen. Zwischen Raststätte Bukosee Ost und Werbelin besteht Gefahr durch eine ungesicherte Unfallstelle. Hier ist die rechte Spur blockiert. A10, östlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreig Schwanenbeck. Zwischen Dreig Spreeau und Freinbring gab es einen Unfall. Hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. A10, östlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreig Pankow. Zwischen Hohenschönhausen und Dreig Schwanenbeck gibt es stockenden Verkehr. A10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Dreig Spreeau und Rastplatz Yüklesee gibt es Behinderungen durch Bergungsarbeiten. A12, Frankfurt Oder, Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Frankfurt Oder Süd und Frankfurt Oder West gab es einen Unfall mit dem LKW, der blockiert jetzt die rechte Spur. A24, Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Raststätte Linumer Bruch Süd und Kremen gab es einen Unfall. Hier ist die PAN-Spur blockiert. Und letzte Meldung aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin. A100 und A111 in allen Richtungen immer mal wieder Stau und stoppender Verkehr. Prinzipiell gilt, fahrt vorsichtig, es kann glatt werden. Davos geht euch eine gute Fahrt. Spritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Spritz in Berlin. Am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, dem 27. Januar, ist natürlich das Chaosradio. Heute hier zu Gast sind Nico Longolius und Frank Rosengard, der erste mit einer eigenen Firma, die Cloud Computing benutzt und der andere vom Chaos Computer Club, weil ist ja das Chaos Radio. Cloud Computing, so haben wir vorher gelernt, ist es, wenn man sich Rechenzeit im Netz irgendwie mieten kann. Und jetzt wollen wir wissen, wann ihr das nutzt. Und dafür erzählen Frank und Nico erstmal, wofür man das überhaupt nutzen kann. So als ganz normaler Typ, der vom Rechner sitzt. Also vielleicht noch mal das klassischste Beispiel dazu ist ein sogenanntes Online-Backup. Die Idee ist, dass ich einfach Sachen bei mir auf meinem Rechner hab. Und ich hab Angst, dass sie weg sind, wenn meine Festplatte kaputt geht oder mein Laptop geklaut wird oder sowas. Das heißt, ich will irgendwo ein Backup machen. Der einfachste Weg wäre dafür, eine externe Festplatte zu kaufen, alles rauf zu tun. Vielleicht gibt es aber auch einen guten Grund, warum ich das nicht haben will oder ich kann mir das gerade nicht leisten und will einfach ein paar Sachen ganz sicher irgendwo im Internet hinterlegen. Oder ich will irgendwelche Sachen vielleicht auch mal jemand anders zugänglich machen, wobei dann geht es schon wieder in diesem Bereich Internet Sharing oder sowas. Also dass ich einfach Dateien jemand anders zugänglich machen will. Das ist natürlich eine andere Sache bei den Sicherheitsfragen. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt mein ganz privates Backup machen will, dann will ich es natürlich so machen, dass möglichst nur ich an diese Daten wieder rankomme. Also dass es wirklich eine private Sache bleibt. Eine andere Variante wäre, wenn ich sage, ich habe hier einfach Daten und die will ich irgendwie anderen Leuten zugänglich machen. Also das ist jetzt nicht so strukturiert, wie ich mache eine Webseite, will vielleicht auch nicht irgendwie die Beschränkung von einer MySpace oder Facebook-Seite haben, sondern ich habe einfach irgendwie da 200 Fotos und will die irgendwelchen Leuten zugänglich machen. Dann kann ich dadurch einen Dienst mir suchen, der mir das anbietet, wo ich einfach einen Speicherplatz habe im Netz irgendwo und ich lade die Sachen da hoch, die Fotos und dann sind die da online und die Leute können sie einsehen. Wenn ich jetzt dieses Online-Backup mache, dann heißt es, dass ich ja wirklich meine privaten Daten diesem Anbieter anvertraue. Also da kommt dieser Begriff Vertrauen wieder rein, weil ich muss ihm natürlich weit vertrauen und er wird mir das vielleicht auch versprechen oder zumindest zusagen. Vertrauen Sie uns. Wir halten Ihre Daten sicher. Dass diese Daten da wirklich dann sicher sind und auch dann in keine fremden Hände kommen. Da würde mich jetzt wirklich mal interessieren, wer da draußen jetzt sitzt und denkt, genau das mache ich auch. Ich habe irgendwie keine Ahnung, ich schreibe gerade mal eine Diplomarbeit und weil ich immer braven Backup mache, das mache ich halt irgendwie online, weil das ist super. Also wer von euch nutzt Online-Backups und hat vielleicht schon mal Erfahrungen damit gemacht, die er erzählen will, ist genau die Nummer, die ihr anrufen könnt oder halt auch im Chat mitmachen. Die Links dazu gibt es auf fritz.de. Ein ganz klassischer Dienst ist eigentlich, kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle, ist ein Webmail-Dienst, das heißt also gmxweb.de wie sie alle heißen, Hotmail, wo ich kein E-Mail-Programm habe, was eigentlich früher oder normalerweise auch immer noch der Standard ist, dass ich wirklich dann ein E-Mail-Programm wie Outlook oder Thunderbird oder sonst was auf meinem Rechner habe, sondern es ist alles webbasiert, das heißt ich gehe mit meinem Browser auf eine Seite und benutze dann die E-Mail oder mein E-Mail-System in diesem Browser, das heißt es ist wirklich eine rein virtuelle Sache, ich muss nichts mehr installieren bei mir auf dem Rechner und ich habe auch gar nichts mehr zum Anfassen, sondern es ist wirklich alles komplett im Netz, das ist eigentlich auch ein sehr klassischer Cloud-Dienst, wobei es bei den meisten Anbietern noch so einigermaßen bestimmt ist, wo die sind. Also bei GMX kann ich davon ausgehen, dass die in Deutschland die Server haben und ich habe da einen Anbieter und der hat auch ein eigenes Rechenzentrum, wobei, wer weiß das noch, vielleicht hat das auch nicht, vielleicht hat das auch schon alles in die Cloud ausgelagert, aber ich habe irgendwie nicht mehr wirklich was zum Anfassen an dieser Software, also ich kann die halt einfach gar nicht weg installieren von meinem Rechner, sondern die ist da einfach nicht. Im Prinzip brauche ich keinen Rechner mehr, aber ich brauche noch irgendwas, womit ich ins Internet komme.
Genau.
Gibt es denn typische Cloud-Probleme? Dass das Internet weg ist. Ja, das ist ein typisches Cloud-Problem. Also wenn ich einfach mit den E-Mails bei mir auf meinem Rechner lokal habe, dann komme ich da immer ran, egal ob ich Internet habe oder nicht. Also ich komme zwar keine neuen und kann keine verschicken, aber immerhin an meine alten E-Mails, die ich da gespeichert habe, komme ich ran. So insofern ist einfach klar der schlimmste anzunehmende Unfall, sozusagen ist, dass das Internet weg ist, weil irgendwie gerade vor meinem Haus der Bagger irgendwie die DSN-Leitung durchtrennt hat oder was auch immer, oder dass natürlich der Anbieter, der die Sachen anbietet, dann auch weg ist, was natürlich auch in der schwunghaften Wirtschaft auch immer mal wieder passieren kann, dass ich irgendwo einen Dienst habe und da alle meine Fotos gelagert habe oder vielleicht alle meine E-Mails oder noch andere wichtige Dokumente und plötzlich stelle ich fest, dieser Server ist einfach nicht mehr erreichbar und irgendwie, was los? Naja, wird schon in einer Stunde wieder gehen, geht nicht in einer Stunde, geht auch nach einer Woche nicht mehr. Und dann finde ich dann raus, dieser Anbieter ist einfach pleite gegangen, der ist einfach weg. Gibt es irgendwie Beispiele? Also, hat das vielleicht da draußen schon mal jemand erlebt? Irgendwie war er bei einem Online-Dienst und dann zack, war auf einmal weg. 0331 70 97 110 wäre die Nummer für diese Geschichten. Habt ihr da, kennt jeder was?
Ja, also vielleicht fängst du an mit dem Sidekick-Fall.
Genau, da ist es ja nicht so, dass der Internet-Anbieter pleite gegangen ist, aber ein klassischer Fall von irgendwie, ich habe meine Kontaktdaten von meinem, wie sagt man das zu, Personal Digital Assistant, also einfach so wie ein Blackberry oder so. Sidekick ist in den USA von T-Mobile ein spezielles Gerät, was mit dem, was so auch mit, also quasi Cloud-Services kommt. Das heißt, wenn man dieses Gerät hat, wird automatisch auch immer, alles was man da drauf macht, wird hochgeladen auf den, irgendwo der Infrastruktur. Da gab es auch zwischendurch mal viel lustige Sachen, weil irgendein, von irgendwie Promis das Ding gehackt wurde oder sowas. Ja, also klar, das kann natürlich auch mit meinem normalen Email-Account passieren, aber was das Dramatische an der Geschichte ist, dass sich natürlich auch ganz viele Leute darauf verlassen haben, so T-Mobile, irgendwie kann ich ja meine Daten, das ist alles super, und haben ihre Kontaktdaten dahin sozusagen verbracht. Und eines Tages hatten die da ein Hardware-Problem. Das Hardware-Problem sah so aus, dass der große zentrale Festplattenspeicher einfach im Arsch war. Also er war einfach kaputt, der war hinüber, da ist ihm irgendwas abgebrannt oder sowas. Dieses Ding war einfach nicht mehr da. Also die Daten waren einfach weg. Dann ging es darum, dann hat man versucht, mit dem Hersteller die Sachen wieder zu restaurieren. Das war aber alles so mehr oder weniger erfolgreich. Letztendlich war es einfach so, dass wirklich ein Teil der Daten einfach weg war. Man hat die Leute mit 100 Dollar entschädigt, hat gesagt, sorry, eure Kontakte sind alle weg. Ist halt so. Das ist eigentlich so ein ganz klassischer Fall dafür, wo man dann auch überlegen muss, okay. Ich muss kurz an eine Verständnis verstellen, diese Sidekicks sind auch so konstruiert, dass sie quasi nur online funktionieren. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das online Gegenstück weg ist, sind die Daten auf dem Gerät auch weg, oder wie läuft das? Also man kann sich auch lokalen Backup machen und einige Leute haben das auch gemacht. Aber natürlich, wer das nicht hatte, da hatte der da einen Datenverlust. Okay, also das Gerät selber sozusagen braucht irgendwo so ein Backup, das hält die Daten nicht von alleine vor. Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, aber es war auf jeden Fall für viele Leute ein großes Drama. Insofern gehe ich davon aus, dass man da irgendwie eine Verbindung hat, genau.
Meine Lieblingspleite, eine Geschichte in ähnlicher Größenordnung, die uns getroffen hat, ist, uns ist mal ein Rechenzentrum abgebrannt. Richtig physisch, also es hat da drin gebrannt. Und da wir das Ganze in Cloud-Diensten verwendet haben, wussten wir ja auch nicht mehr, wo unsere Computer stehen, weil die können ja überall auf der Welt stehen. Das heißt, diese Veranstaltung war wahnsinnig schwer zu debuggen, wie man so schön sagt, weil es war einfach einer unserer Computer, war kaputt. Es hat sich in dem Fall um den DNS-Server gehandelt. Der Anbieter war in dem Moment nicht zu erreichen. Und es hat bei uns eine Weile gedauert, bis wir herausbekommen haben, dass das Fisher Plaza in Seattle, glaube ich, ein großes Rechenzentrum, einfach brannte. Und dass dieses Problem glücklicherweise in dem Fall nicht nur uns getroffen hat, sondern auch noch andere große Seiten, zum Beispiel Bing, stand da auch gleich.
Aber da hat es weniger wehgetan, weil es auch anderen...
Nein, für mich war es einfach ein beruhigendes Gefühl. Nach kurzer Zeit war klar, dass in dem gleichen Rechenzentrum authorized.net heißen, die, glaube ich, auch abgebrannt ist, beziehungsweise das Rechenzentrum hat nicht gebrannt, aber der Transformator hat gebrannt. Der stand im Keller, der Keller hatte eine Sprinkelanlage, es gab einen Backup-Transformator, durch die Sprinkelanlage stand der zweite Transformator aber auch unter Wasser und dann war der Strom aus. Das ist sozusagen die Kurzform. Und mit uns in dem Rechenzentrum auch auf dieser Cloud war mit drinnen authorize.net, die wickeln einen Großteil der US-amerikanischen Kreditkartentransaktionen. Und in dem Moment war mir einfach klar, ich muss da überhaupt niemanden am Telefon erreichen. Das ist jetzt einfach Pech. Ja, aber da kümmern sich jetzt sehr engagierte Leute darum, dass das möglichst schnell wieder funktioniert. Das muss ich gar nicht tun.
Wie lange hat das gedauert?
Das hat in dem Fall fast zwei Tage gedauert.
Also sagen, eine relativ wichtige Infrastruktur, wo relativ große Dinge dran hängen, hat zwei Tage gedauert, um die auf dem Vordermann zu bringen.
Da hat es einfach mal so richtig das Herz erwischt. Das war der 3. Juli des letzten Jahres. Also ein Tag vor dem Feiertag. Also am 4. geht in den USA halt gar nichts. Und genau, das hat, ich glaube, knapp 48 Stunden gedauert.
Habt ihr in eurer Firma, habt ihr denn was geändert an eurem Cloud Computing? Oder ist das was, da muss man einfach mit rechnen?
Also wir, das Problem bei Cloud Computing sind immer nicht die Fehler, an die man denkt. An die denken sehr viele andere Leute. Das Problem sind die Fehler, an die man nicht denkt. Also es ist vielleicht ein guter Moment, um einmal mein Lieblings Douglas Adams Zitat anzubringen. Ich hoffe, es funktioniert im Radio. Adams hat mal geschrieben, der Unterschied zwischen einer Sache, die überhaupt nicht kaputtgehen kann und einer Sache, die kaputtgehen kann, ist, wenn die Sache, die nicht kaputtgehen kann, kaputtgeht, kann man sie überhaupt nicht reparieren. Und das trifft auf dieses Cloud Computing genauso zu. Das heißt, durch diese komplett neue Form, Computer miteinander zu vernetzen, Rechenpower zu virtualisieren. Speicher stellt man sich ja irgendwie immer als eine Festplatte vor, die man in den Schrank stellt. Auf einmal ist Speicher was komplett Virtuelles. Vielleicht sind sogar Teile meiner einen Datei liegen in einem Rechenzentrum, andere Teile der gleichen Datei liegen in einem anderen Rechenzentrum. Es ist einfach nicht mehr zu fassen. Und diese Infrastruktur produziert einfach Fehler oder Missstände, an die konnte vorher einfach keiner denken.
Wie sieht das aus, also wenn ich jetzt eine normale Festplatte habe, dann gibt es sozusagen für die meisten Geräte eine Untersuchung. Die haben einen Durchschnitt in der Lebenszeit von so und so und eine Fehlerprozentzahl von so und so. Wenn ich irgendwie vier Festplatten zu einem Rate irgendwas zusammenbaue, dann senke ich damit die Chance, dass irgendwas ausfällt. Cloud Computer gibt es da auch sozusagen.
Genau, es geht einfach auch kaputt. Ich glaube also in dem Fall habe ich die Zahl gelesen. Amazon sagt an, dass die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit für eine Datei, die auf ihrem Speicher liegt, bei 0, 1 Prozent im Jahr ist.
Ist das gut?
Das ist, glaube ich, eine Information. Das ist gegenüber einer Festplatte, die ich mir bei meinem Elektronikfachmarkt kaufen kann, verflucht gut. Für eine Geschichte, wo ich irgendwas für die Ewigkeit plane, ist das verdammt schlecht.
Was mache ich denn, wenn ich was für die Ewigkeit plane?
Ich muss mehrere Backups anlegen.
Also das heißt mehrere Cloud-Dienste dann irgendwie organisieren. Also wobei gerade nochmal zurück zu diesem abgebrannten Rechenzentrum oder dem Transformator was gebrannt hat, das wäre natürlich mit einer klassischen IT genauso ein Problem gewesen. Nur hast du dann natürlich möglicherweise als große Firma, für die es wirklich überlebenswichtig ist, hast du entsprechende Pläne und du kannst dann auch die Leute entsprechend treten, dass sie halt das Ganze nicht in zwei Tagen beheben, sondern vielleicht in vier Stunden oder so was. Das heißt also du hast dann einfach da auch mehr Möglichkeiten Druck auszuüben, wenn du wirklich selbst über diese IT-Infrastruktur verfügen kannst. Und du hast dann eine gewisse Verlässlichkeit. Also es gibt zwar auch irgendwelche Zusagen, was die Verfügbarkeit angeht bei den Diensten, aber die sind dann halt auch eher, also ich würde halt immer zwischen einer Ansage, also das, was sie sozusagen auf der Webseite versprechen, und einer wirklichen Garantie. Das heißt also, wenn sie jetzt das nicht einhalten können, was kriegst du denn von denen? Also kriegst du denn wirklich deinen geschäftlichen Schaden ersetzt oder kriegst du dann halt einfach eine monatliche Grundgebühr von 100 Dollar zurückerstattet? Das ist immer so eine Sache. Also was ist das eine, was die versprechen, dass sie sagen, ja, wir haben 99, 9 irgendwas Prozent und wenn sie das aber nicht einhalten, dann muss man einfach schauen, ok, was machen wir dann? Und dann ist natürlich dann der große Unterschied zwischen dem Rechenzentrum, was ich selbst in der Kontrolle habe und dem diesen Cloud-Diensten oder diesen virtualisierten Diensten, die dann halt irgendwo sind, wo ich halt irgendwo einen Vertragspartner hab, der auch, den ich vielleicht auch gerichtlich gar nicht so gut greifen kann, weil der irgendwie in einem Land sitzt, die einfach eine ganz andere Rechtsordnung haben, wo irgendwelche Gerichtsverfahren wahnsinnig teuer werden, wo vielleicht auch ganz andere gesetzliche Regelungen hinsichtlich Haftungen gelten. Also auch gerade beim Datenschutz ist es noch ein Punkt, da kommen wir dann auch noch zu später. Also damit muss ich mich ja auseinandersetzen, dass ich einfach nicht mehr so dieses klassische wir sind hier in Deutschland und hier funktioniert es so, Punkt, das funktioniert dann da einfach nicht mehr an der Stelle. Wie ist das jetzt? Wir haben jetzt sozusagen schon, also Anwendung für den normalen, die zu Hause ist, zum Beispiel Online-Backup. Wenn du es so erzählst, denke ich so, eigentlich ist es nicht wirklich sinnvoll. Also es ist irgendwie sinnvoll, wenn ich für mein zweites oder drittes Backup, um das irgendwie noch vorzuhalten und online auch verfügbar zu haben, aber sozusagen Backup im Sinne von, ich möchte eine sichere Kopie haben, ist dann eigentlich dann nicht gegeben.
Na doch, es ist natürlich erstmal, muss man sagen, dass die großen Cloud-Dienste, alle wie sie heute präsent sind, eine deutlich bessere Datensicherheit bieten und damit meine ich nicht Privatsphäre, sondern damit meine ich die Erhaltung von Daten.
Also die technische Datensicherheit.
Die technische Datensicherheit bieten. Als es mir eine zweite Festplatte bieten würde, die ich in den Schrank lege. Darf man abgesehen, dass wenn meine Wohnung brennt, sowieso beide kaputt sind, da kann ich so viele wie ich will in meinen Schrank hineinlegen, ist es einfach auch so, dass natürlich innerhalb dieser großen Anbieter mit so großen IT-Infrastrukturen natürlich Sicherheitskonzepte fahren, die weit über das hinausgehen, was ich als Privatperson machen kann. Ich glaube nur, da muss ich Frank recht geben, es gibt natürlich diesen einen psychologischen, aber auch faktischen Moment, ich habe einfach keinen mehr der Schuld ist. Also die Wolke ist Schuld, ist so ein dober Moment, wenn wirklich was teures kaputt gegangen ist. Da ist es natürlich eine Telefonnummer und ein Vornamen zu haben, einfach besser. Und für einen selber zu Hause gilt es natürlich auch, dieses Gefühl, hier habe ich eine DVD oder eine Festplatte oder einen sonstigen Datenträger, da sind meine Backups drauf, hat, glaube ich, subjektiv erst mal ein höheres Gefühl der Sicherheit, als es diese virtuelle Cloud hat.
Was lernen wir daraus? Man kann nie genug Backups haben. Also eins für zu Hause, eins zum Einschließen irgendwo und eins in der Cloud am besten.
Super.
Wollen wir mal über Sicherheit von so Cloud-Dingen generell reden und THS dazu holen? Wir haben nämlich noch einen Experten am Start. THS ist aus dem Clubumfeld und ist jemand, der sich schon mal ausführlicher mit der Cloud und ihrer Sicherheit beschäftigt hat. Lohnt guten Abend. Lass mich die Frage ganz einfach stellen. Ist Cloud Computing sicher?
So gesehen bin ich jetzt nicht der Cloud Computing Experte oder so. Das will ich so nicht sagen. Nee, ich hab mir halt immer Teile da angeguckt, wo das halt auch mein Job ist. Ich dachte mir, das ist immer ganz interessant, da vielleicht auch noch mal das eine oder andere beizutragen. Was ja heute schon häufiger angesprochen wurde, ist sowas wie Vertrauen oder so. Da werden virtuelle Festplatten oder irgendwelche Dinge, auf denen man seine persönlichen Daten ablegt, die werden behandelt, als würden sie bei einem unterm Schreibtisch stehen. Da wird einiges ausgeblendet oder eben, da denkt man vielleicht nicht dran.
Kannst du ein bisschen genauer beschreiben, in welcher Form du damit zu tun hattest?
Ja, ich hatte halt im Rahmen eines Auftrags, das ist halt eine kommerzielle Geschichte, eine sehr detaillierte Sicht auf so ein gesamtes Konzept eines Online-Backups. Also nicht nur das Konzept und diese ganze Architektur, die dahinter liegt, sondern auch die einzelnen Dienste, die dann da serverseitig laufen und was eben auch kleinseitig auf den einzelnen PCs installiert wird und wie das Ganze so funktioniert.
Das heißt, du hast die Software von innen angesehen sozusagen? Gleich ausführlicher, aber kurze Frage. Würdest du nach dem, was du da untersucht hast, den bei deinem Backup auf dem Dienst benutzen?
Das hätte ich aber auch vorher nicht getan, glaube ich.
Okay, warum nicht?
Also wenn es um so eine Sache wie Backups geht, ich finde Backups sind extrem wichtig. Das weiß eigentlich jeder, der schon mal mit einem Datenverlust zu kämpfen hatte. Aber es handelt sich doch größtenteils um Daten, die man einfach nicht unbekannten Menschen anvertrauen will. Und wenn das nur Bilder von der letzten Party sind, das geht einfach niemandem was an. Das zeige ich fürstens meinen Freunden ausgewählt im Kreis oder so. Aber es ging ja gerade heute auch mehrfach durch die Medien, dass es irgendwelche Studien gibt, die zeigen, dass Firmenbosse oder irgendwelche Chefs-Beinstellungen auch im Internet recherchieren und so weiter. Und die Gefahr, dass aus so einer Cloud Daten geklaut werden, ist natürlich höher, als wenn man die Daten über sich zu Hause und am Schreibtisch speichert auf einer Festplatte.
Inwiefern? Weil mehr Leute Zugriff darauf haben, weil ich nicht weiß, wo das liegt, oder weil es auch technisch unsicherer ist?
Das hängt von meinten ab, aber die Gefahr ist natürlich da, denn ich geb meine Daten ja in dritte Hände, also in die Hände von irgendwelchen Unternehmen, die eigentlich ein ausschließlich kommerzielles Interesse haben. Und Menschen machen Fehler, Unternehmen machen Fehler. Manche Unternehmen betreiben so eine Dienste auch, um Daten zu sammeln, haben irgendwelche Klauseln vielleicht, die dann halt das auch rechtlich auf eine mehr oder weniger fragwürdige Ebene hieschen, aber die machen halt Fehler unter Umständen. Und wenn man sich dann mal ansieht, wenn die mal Angriffsziel von irgendwelchen Hackern werden oder irgendwelche Script-Kitties, die halt irgendwas gefunden haben, dann kann man halt leicht irgendwie dann da eben mit betroffen von sein. Wenn dann da Daten tatsächlich mal liegen sollten, wenn das unverschüssete Daten sind oder Daten, die nur schlecht gesichert auf den Servern liegen, dann sind die unter Umständen im Internet und einmal im Internet kriegt man es halt auch nicht wieder weg.
Du hast also grundsätzliche Bedenken gegen überhaupt, sagen Backup in der Cloud zu machen. Hast du denn bei dem, was du untersucht hast, hast du da konkret so Schwachstellen gefunden, wo du denkst, hey, das kann aber richtig böse in die Hose gehen?
Ja, das ist natürlich, also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt so besonders exemplarisch ist für alle diese Dienste. Das will ich definitiv nicht sagen. Ich habe auch noch nicht so viele solcher Dienste gesehen. Aber was die da falsch gemacht haben, das war noch mal so ein richtiger Realitätsabgleich. Weil die haben eigentlich alles falsch gemacht. Also das ging wirklich von einer Ebene. Die Implementierungen, die waren C. Das heißt, diese Kleins gab es dann zum Beispiel für Windows-Systeme. Und die hatten so diese klassischen Buffer-Overflow-Schwachstellen, obwohl die eigentlich auch moderne Frameworks verwendet haben, die sowas unterbinden. Und dann halt sehr, sehr viel auf logischer Ebene, was man halt auch nicht so ohne Weiteres durch irgendwelche automatisierten Tests finden kann.
Das heißt, die haben schlappig gearbeitet einfach auch?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Die haben das bestimmt alles nicht mutwillig gemacht. Das war einfach so. Ich glaube, da sitzen dann so ein paar Leute und die denken, hey, lass uns mal ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Wir sammeln ein paar Buzzwords und schmeißen alles in die große Wolke und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert. Und dann nehmen die sowas wie Online-Backup und Kryptografie. Kryptografie ist sicher und das müssen wir jetzt auch damit einbauen. Und Cloud, ja ja, Cloud, los, ein bisschen Cloud noch dazu. Und dann kommen zum Teil Sachen raus, die sind schlecht durchdacht. Da hat halt jemand mal angefangen zu programmieren und dann wurde daraus irgendwann ein Produkt gemacht. Und naja, das sieht halt dann so aus, dass das vom Design her zum Teil wirklich so arg verkackt ist, dass das irreparabel kaputt war, was zum Beispiel auch die Kryptographie angeht. Also es gibt ja da verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man sowas grundsätzlich mal sicher machen kann, dass eben kleinzeitig verschlüsselt wird und die Daten nur...
Also quasi ich verschlüssel auf meinem eigenen Rechner und dann wird das Verschlüsselte hochgeladen und dann kann auch niemand mehr ran außer mir.
Genau, das darf man natürlich nicht falsch interpretieren, wenn man sich so SSL anguckt, wo die Daten eigentlich nur getunnelt werden, aber dann doch in Klartext abgespeichert werden. Das ist vielleicht auch nochmal so ein Missverständnis bei vielen Leuten. Aber wenn man die Daten tatsächlich mit einem anständigen, gut abgehangenen Krypto-Verfahren lokal auf seinem Rechner verschlüsselt und das Ganze dann überträgt, dann sollte theoretisch der Anbieter dieses Backup-Systems keinen Zugriff auf die Daten haben.
Das ist auch das Einzige, wie du deine Daten auch hochladen würdest.
Sowas kann man durchaus machen. Das ist überhaupt keine Frage, wenn man diesen Krypto-Algorithmen vertraut.
Das würde uns jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu weit führen. Hast du denn selber oder kannst du eine Empfehlung geben an die Hörer, wenn man selber so einen Backup-Dienst benutzt, wie man erkennen kann, ob der sicher ist oder nicht. Oder ob da sozusagen so gearbeitet wurden, wie du das gerade beschrieben hast bei deinem Fall.
Da kann man eigentlich so ja nun nicht tun. Also das ist ja genauso wie nicht möglich, wie man sagen kann, daran erkennst du, ob dein Betriebssystem unsicher ist. Das erkennt man eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Das kann man höchstens am eigenen Verhalten festmachen. Also ich kann ein System halt so sicher oder unsicher bedienen, wie ich mich mit diesem System auskenne. Es wird halt niemand tatsächlich ernsthaft irgendwie dieser Anwendung, die da dieses Backup durchführt, in der Tiefe analysieren, wie wir es da getan haben. Ja, das geht glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit. Man begibt sich in eine gewisse Abhängigkeit und muss sich das schon sehr gut überlegen, ob man das tatsächlich macht, gerade was eben so private Daten angeht. Also das wäre halt meine Empfehlung. Man muss halt ganz genau wissen, worauf man sich da einlässt. Und ich glaube, da ist die Aufklärung einfach viel wichtiger. Also sicherlich gibt es Daten, die man auch da irgendwie woanders backupen kann. Das ist überhaupt kein Thema. Aber ich habe auch lieber verschlüsselte Festplatten, USB-Platten, die ich dann halt irgendwie so durchzeige jede Woche eine andere oder alle zwei Wochen. Und die verteile ich dann auch noch im Kreis von Leuten, denen ich vertraue, dass ich die halt auch an unterschiedlichen Orten habe.
Man könnte also sagen, du hast dir einen Online-Better-Cup-Dienst in der Cloud genauer angeguckt und wirst deshalb den nicht mehr benutzen. Du sagtest ja auch, es ist ein Einzelfall, aber es ist, finde ich, schon auch ein bisschen bezeichnet.
Ich denke, das trifft so ziemlich auf einen Großteil dieser kommerziellen Unternehmen zu, die überhaupt so eine Dienste anbieten. Weil die haben ja nicht das Interesse, dich besonders gut abzusichern. Die wollen in erster Linie Geld verdienen. Und es gibt natürlich ein paar Ausnahmen, keine Frage. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wie du sagen willst, sollte man am Hinterkopf behalten. Wie das bei diesen anderen typischen Cloud-Diensten aussieht, kann ich das natürlich nicht beurteilen. Das ist dann tatsächlich vielleicht doch eher so dieser praktische Fall, wie dieses sehr mal eben schnell so ein Batzen Server mieten. Das ist wahrscheinlich schon ganz praktisch.
Aber immerhin ein Einbeginn, ein einzelnes Beispiel haben wir erhalten. Vielen Dank, THS. Wisst ihr beiden, ob man das verallgemeinern kann? Also ich würde gerne nochmal auf diese verschiedenen Verschlüsselungsvarianten eingehen danach. Aber da muss man einfach schauen, wie oder was versprechen, oder zumindest wie funktionieren genau diese Anbieter. Also gerade bei diesen Online-Backups gibt es eine ziemlich breite Spanne von Anbietern, wie sie funktionieren. Dann hab ich persönlich für mich mal so eine Einteilung gemacht, einfach in diese wirklichen Online-Backups. Das heißt, da kann ich wirklich mit gutem oder mehr oder weniger gutem Gewissen diese Daten hingeben und glaub, dass sie da recht gut aufgehoben sind. Oder eben diese Sharing-Anbieter, wo ich sag, ich hab zwar mal mein Backup, aber eigentlich ist mir das auch egal, wenn die Sachen alle im Internet sind. Das sind halt irgendwelche Fotos, die sowieso alle sehen können oder sowas. Das sind dann Sachen, Dienste, die vielleicht sogar als Online-Backup beworben werden, die aber letztendlich einfach so unsicher sind, dass man einfach davon ausgehen muss, dass diese Daten irgendwo im Netz sind. Und da gibt es einfach verschiedene Varianten, an welcher Stelle ich die Daten verschlüssel oder wer Herr über diese Verschlüsselung ist. Und da unterscheiden sich die Backup-Anbieter schon ziemlich. Also da sollte man einfach mal einen Testbericht anschauen, vielleicht in einer CT oder anderen Computer-Zeitschrift, wo auch gerade dieser Sicherheitsaspekt dann mal getestet wurde. Also es gibt Anbieter, die das sehr vorbildlich machen, die also wirklich mir das komplett überlassen, diese Verschlüsselung, und wo ich denn Herr über diese Verschlüsselung bin, bis zu Anbieter, die einfach überhaupt gar nichts verschlüsseln. Also weder bei mir, bevor es irgendwie zum Online-Backup geht, oder auf dem Transportweg, oder bei sich, sondern das ist halt eigentlich wie die Sachen auf die Homepage stellen. Also wenn man Cloud Computing benutzt, um ein Backup zu machen, dann sollte man aufpassen, dass es A ein vertrauenswürdiger Anbieter ist und B seine Sachen am besten verschlüsseln. Mit dem Vertrauenswürdig, der werden wir gleich nochmal genauer drauf eingehen. Chaos Radio im Blue Moon am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Es geht heute um Cloud Computing. Das ist quasi so eine Art digitale Leiharbeiter. Ihr sagt, ich will eigentlich nicht den ganzen Computer mieten, sondern ich will einfach nur meinen Online-Backup irgendwo hinpacken oder so eine kleine Webseite programmieren, die ein bisschen mehr Rechennutzung braucht als so ein normaler Webspace. Dazu kann man das nutzen. Wir haben heute schon darüber geredet, was das kann. Wir haben auch schon darüber geredet, was es nicht kann. Wir sind jetzt gerade bei Backups. Bevor wir damit aber weitermachen, wie man einen guten Cloud Computing Backup-Dienst erkennt und ob es das überhaupt gibt, gibt es ein bisschen Musik. Die kommt aus dem Netz, also quasi auch aus der Cloud. Zehn Jahre alte Netzmusik, aber immer noch gut von Will B. Der hat sein erstes Album wieder neu rausgebracht. Nach zehn Jahren Remastered gibt es umsonsten kostenlos im Netz. Es ist Creative Commons Musik und den Link dazu gibt es im Wiki zur Chaosradio Sendung, denn da seid ihr gerade gelandet. Chaosradio 153, um die Nummer auch mal zu sagen. Es geht um Cloud Computing. Herr Rosengard vom Chaos Computer Club ist auch hier zu Gast. Kannst du noch mal kurz in drei Sätzen zusammenfassen, was Cloud Computing ist? Cloud Computing sind virtuelle Leiharbeiter im Netz. Die Cloud ist das unbekannte Internetwesen. Das ist irgendwie so eine graue, diffuse Wolke. Eine Theorie ist, es kommt aus den Powerpoint-Präsentationen von IT-lern. Es gibt bei Powerpoint so ein Wolken-Symbol und diese Wolke, das ist das Internet. Da sind halt irgendwelche Sachen, da sind halt irgendwelche User, da sind irgendwelche Server und da passiert irgendwas. Wir wissen nicht genau, wo die Rechner stehen, wer das ist, wieviel das sind, was sie für Kapazität haben, aber das ist halt so diese diffuse Wolke, da passiert irgendwas, da kommt möglicherweise dieser Begriff Cloud Computing her. Und die Idee ist, dass man einfach bei Cloud Computing vor allem Dienste, Server, also irgendwelche Angebote oder irgendwelche Software, die auf diesen Servern läuft, die wird zusammen mit diesen Servern komplett virtualisiert. Das heißt, ich kann hier einfach stundenweise mieten oder monatsweise, muss mir keine eigenen Server irgendwo in den Keller stellen, sondern ich miete halt einfach irgendwann nicht nur, also entweder Speicherkapazität, das kann auch sein in Form von virtuellen Festplatten oder auch noch gleich die Computing Power, also die Rechenleistung, um damit dann irgendwas zu tun. Das kann ein einfacher Web-Server sein, wo ich einfach irgendwelche Webseiten habe, irgendwelche Firmen-Webseiten, das kann sein, ich will irgendwie eine große Werbekampagne lauschen mit einer Firma und ich habe aber selbst nur einen Server zur Verfügung oder vielleicht zwei für meine Webseite und ich weiß aber, es kommen jetzt irgendwie Millionen Leute, klicken Punkt 18 auf die Webseite und bricht meinen Server zusammen, dann kann ich natürlich sagen, okay, ich miete mir einfach noch 20 andere Server, aber dann habe ich diese Server oder ich kaufe die Server und habe sie einfach dann zu stehen und danach langweilen die sich einfach. Was ich jetzt machen kann mit der Cloud ist, dass ich einfach irgendwo bei irgendwie Anbietern, der bekannteste ist wahrscheinlich Amazon, virtuelle Server-Kapazität dazumiete und dann zu dieser Lastspitze, wenn sie kommt, einfach diese Server hochfahre und die Last entsprechend verteile. Also das ist zumindest so die Theorie, da brauchst du natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr Aufwand zu. Ich müsste diese ganzen Anfragen, die dann auch kommen, verteilen. Also die ganzen Leute, die klicken, müssen ja auch dann auf diese virtuellen Server entsprechend verteilt werden. Da gibt es aber auch mittlerweile Systeme, die das schon einfach machen. Aber das ist so die Idee hinter der Cloud. Das heißt, dass ich wirklich on-demand, also wenn ich sie brauche, einfach Server-Kapazität hochfahren kann. Interessante Idee, darauf möchte ich gleich nochmal zurückkommen. Wir hatten jetzt gerade noch drüber gesprochen, was dem, ich nenne ihn jetzt mal normalen User, am ehesten glaube ich, es sind Dienste, die selber die Cloud benutzen, um ihre Dienste zu betreiben. Also Twitter zum Beispiel oder Facebook wahrscheinlich auch. Und es geht auch um Backup-Dienste. Also sagen einfach, man kann sich da Speicherplatz mieten und die Anbieter solcher online Backup-Festplatten, die sind halt meistens auch irgendwie in dieser seltsamen Cloud unterwegs. Du hast vorhin erzählt, dass du sozusagen für dich diese Anbieter irgendwie unterteilt hast, sind solche, denen man seine Daten schon irgendwie anvertrauen kann und solche, wo man genau weiß, naja, also wenn ich nicht sowieso will, dass es überall im Netz ist, dann gehe ich da lieber nicht hin. Woran machst du das fest? Also es gibt ja so zwei Ebenen bei der Cloud. Das eine ist das, was die Anbieter machen. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt eine IT-Firma bin und sage, ich brauche irgendwie Kapazität, dann kann ich diese in Form von virtuellen Servern oder virtuellen Speicherplatz in der Cloud in Anführungszeichen anbieten. Und das andere ist aber für mich als Endbenutzer, dann ist für mich dieses Internet mit den ganzen vielen Diensten, sei es irgendwie Twitter, sei es irgendwie Google Documents oder Google Office-Geschichte, also wo ich Textverarbeitung habe, Tabellenkalkulation oder sowas. Aber selbst eigentlich auch schon ein Webmail-System ist eigentlich auch schon Teil von dieser Cloud und für mich als Nutzer sehe ich dann dieses Internet, ich sehe diese Dienste und ich installiere mir aber selbst keine Software mehr. Ich habe eigentlich nichts auf meinem Rechner außer einem Browser, wo ich dann diese ganzen Cloud-Dienste benutze. Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Trend in den letzten Jahren, dass ich also mal weniger Software bei mir auf dem Rechner installiert habe, also selbst irgendwie Google-Picasa oder sowas. Ich habe einfach kein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm mehr bei mir auf dem Rechner. Warte, jetzt bin ich aber kurz verwirrt. Wir hatten ja nicht gerade über Backups gesprochen und... Genau, und ein klassischer Dienst davon, den ich auch virtualisiere, ist sozusagen die USB-Festplatte, die ich normalerweise irgendwie für meinen Backup an meinen Rechner ranstecke. Die kann ich aber auch wegvirtualisieren sozusagen in die Cloud rein. Und da gibt es irgendwie zahlreiche Anbieter von Online-Backup-Systemen, wo ich teilweise sogar kostenlos, manchmal ist es so, dass ich ein bestimmtes Kontingent habe, 5 GB, 10 GB bekomme ich kostenlos. Und darüber hinaus muss ich dann einfach per GB bezahlen oder per 10 GB, die ich benutze. Und da gibt es verschiedene Anbieter mit verschiedenen Konzepten. Und das Entscheidende dabei ist, dass ich diesem Anbieter ja meine privaten, wahrscheinlich sehr privaten Daten anvertraue. Das heißt also, ich will schon irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass diese Daten dann auch wirklich nur bei mir und diesem Anbieter sind und bei keinem anderen. Und ich muss diesem Anbieter natürlich auch so weit vertrauen, dass er damit nichts Böses anstellt. Und der aller sicherste Weg ist, wenn diese Daten verschlüsselt werden. Und Verschlüsselung ist natürlich irgendwie, klingt erst mal gut auf der Marketingpräsentation und auf der Webseite. Bei uns sind die Daten sicher, es wird alles verschlüsselt. Aber man muss dann schon ganz genau hinschauen, wo wird eigentlich, an welcher Stelle werden diese Daten verschlüsselt und wer genau verschlüsselt und entschlüsselt sie? Oder viel genauer, wer hat diese Schlüssel, um diese Daten dann auch wieder aufzuschließen? Hab ich die, sind die bei mir geheim oder hat der Anbieter? Das heißt also, macht der Anbieter, erzeugt diesen Schlüssel und verschlüsselt diese Daten dann für mich. Das heißt aber auch, dass er natürlich auch wieder den Schlüssel hat, um sie aufzuschließen. Oder ist es so, dass tatsächlich mir diese komplette Verschlüsselung überlassen wird und dann bin ich Herr über diese Daten. Das heißt also, dann sind diese Daten für jemand anderes, der sie hat, also auch für den Anbieter, komplett wertlos. Gibt es überhaupt Dienste, die das anbieten? Ja, es gibt Dienste, die so was eigentlich fast vorbildlich anbieten. Wo ich tatsächlich einen Schlüssel mir selbst erzeugen kann, den kann ich dann zufällig erzeugen, damit mit Copy und Paste in dieses Programm reintun. Und dann werden diese Daten zwar von dem Programm, aber schon mit meinem Schlüssel verschlüsselt. Und wenn ich jetzt mal davon ausgehe, dass die das bei alles ordentlich gemacht haben, alles sauber programmiert haben, dass diese Verschlüsselung auch gut funktioniert, dann ist das durchaus eine Sache, die für mich akzeptabel ist. Also das Wichtige ist, dass ich derjenige bin, der diese Verschlüsselung dann durchführt oder zumindestens den Schlüssel dann auch für mich behalte. Kannst du da Beispiele nennen, wo das funktioniert? Also es ist ein Anbieter, mir fällt der Name gerade nicht ein. Die sitzen in der Schweiz und ich glaube, die sind von LaCie, also so einem Festplattenhersteller, gekauft worden. Ich glaube, es wird jetzt auch unter dem Label und die bieten jetzt als Online-Festplatte ab. Und der ist eigentlich da recht positiv aufgefallen. Das ist auch ein Projekt von der ETH Zürich, also von der Uni Zürich, nicht Uni Zürich, sondern ETH Zürich, also der Technischen Hochschule, und insofern unterstelle ich den mal, dass es ein Projekt ist, das jetzt nicht von Anfang an auf billig billig, möglichst schnell mal so einen Service hochziehen getrimmt war, sondern einfach eine Sache, die so ganz gut durchdacht ist und auch hoffentlich von einem Programmcode her so ist, dass das sauber gemacht ist. Kann man das angucken, ein Programmcode, hat immer irgendjemand verifiziert, also die Art und Weise, wie das verschlüsselt wird? Nein, das geht dann nicht. Also ich meine, ich kann natürlich ganz sicher gehen, dass das der allerbeste Weg, der auf jeden Fall eigentlich auch zu empfehlen ist. Nämlich ich verschlüssel die Daten komplett selber mit einem externen Programm, also zum Beispiel sowas wie TrueCrypt oder auch PGP, gibt es die Möglichkeit, Daten, also Dateien wirklich zu verschlüsseln und dann dieses komplett verschlüsselte hochzuladen. Dann gehen wir natürlich ein paar Features verloren, die möglicherweise sonst möglich wären, nämlich dass ich verschiedene Versionen habe, dass ich nur Teile davon, also nur das, was sich aktualisiert hat, wieder hochlade und so was. Also mir geht ein bisschen an Komfort verloren dabei, aber ist natürlich eigentlich der aller sicherste Weg, dass ich die Daten in einen Container tue. Das heißt, ich mach erstmal ein verschlüsseltes Image, wie so ein CD-Image oder einfach eine Box praktisch oder wie einen Briefumschlag, wo ich die Sachen reintue, verschlüsselte, zuclebe und dann erst hochlade. Das heißt also der Anbieter weiß auch gar nicht, dass diese Daten oder wie die Daten verschlüsselt sind. Wahrscheinlich weiß er nicht mal, dass sie überhaupt verschlüsselt sind, sondern er kriegt halt einfach nur so einen Blob, so einen rauschenden Blob, wie eine diffuse Masse ist. Wenn ihr sichergehen wollt, dass eure Daten in der Cloud nicht erkannt werden, dann werft mir einfach einen Batzen Schleim hin, und zwar verschlüsselten Schleim. Okay, also es gibt sozusagen, es gibt Anbieter in der Cloud, da kann man sagen, okay, das ist wahrscheinlich okay. Keinlich okay, man weiß es aber nie ganz genau. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich sichergehen will, heißt es, Daten in der Cloud abzulegen, heißt es immer selber verschlüsseln. Was mir jetzt gerade aufgefallen ist, die sagt es ja, Cloud Computing ist, da kann man viele 1000 Rechner am Stück sich irgendwie schaffen. Also man kann eine riesige Rechenarmada sich schaffen. Jetzt ist es ja so, viele von den bösen Hackern nutzen ja sehr viel Zeit dafür, um sich sogenannte Botnet zu schaffen. Das heißt, um viele, viele 100 Rechner unter ihre Kontrolle zu bringen und dann irgendwie damit entweder andere Rechner anzugreifen oder irgendwie Spam-Mails zu verschicken oder sowas. Das hat natürlich den Vorteil für einen Hacker, dass das umsonst ist. Oder gibt es ein anderes Wort für einen? Nee, ist einfach egal. Also für den bösen Typen da. Hat so einen Vorteil, dass es umsonst ist, wenn er sich die Botnet organisiert. Aber so ein Cloud Computing ist ja dann eigentlich sehr geil, weil es kostet zwar ein bisschen Geld, aber es ist derbe zuverlässig. Also man hat es sofort am Start, hat quasi unendlich viel Rechenpower. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Computer, wo dann Schluss ist. Und da kann man ja viel Schindluder treiben. Wird das nicht ausgenutzt?
Ja, also das Missbrauchsszenario von Clouds ist natürlich relativ hoch. Es ist halt eine sehr mächtige Infrastruktur und damit kann man auch Schindluder treiben.
Vor allem gerade weil es so eine anonyme Sache ist auch. Also es gibt ja niemand mehr, der irgendwie wo ich hingehen muss, irgendwie Bargeld auf den Tisch legen muss, vielleicht noch einen Ausweis zeigen muss oder sowas. Oder der irgendwie im schlimmsten Fall auch mal mit den Jungs, mit den Baseballkeulen bei mir vorbeikommen kann. Lass mich raten, man braucht Kreditkartendaten, um sowas zu mieten? Richtig. Ich habe eine Idee, wo die herkommen könnten. Okay, also man klaut sich einmal Kreditkartendaten aus dem Netz, setzt dann damit eine Cloud auf, macht dann irgendwie eine riesen Attacke. Genau, dann ist es auch nicht so schlimm, wenn die nach zwei Stunden gesperrt ist oder nach einer Stunde, weil dann hat man sein Ziel erreicht.
Und um die Szenarien eben einmal durchzugehen, das beginnt natürlich bei Mailservern, die Spam-Mail verschicken oder in irgendeiner Art und Weise Spam im Internet hinterlassen, also Spam-Kommentare in Blogs, Spam auf Spam-Accounts, auf Twitter, Facebook-Spams. Alles in dieser Größenordnung ist mit der Cloud sehr gut und in sehr hohem Maße umzusetzen. Das führt dazu, dass wenn man heute versucht, beispielsweise auf der Amazon-Cloud einen Mailserver zu betreiben, man schon mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit davon ausgehen kann, dass der bei vielen Anbietern geblacklisted ist. Also um das zu erklären, das ist so. Die Leute, die selber Mailserver betreiben, führen Listen von bösen Computern. Also von Computern, von denen erwarten sie, da kommt sowieso nur Müll raus. Deshalb lesen wir von dem aus Prinzip gar keine Mail.
Ich hätte beinahe gesagt, dass das so eine Art Bildzeitung ist.
Ja, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit heute, wenn ich mir irgendeinen beliebigen Server ziehe, dass sich dieser schon mal in einem Adressraum befunden hat, aus dem so viel Quatsch getrieben wurde, dass der von Anbietern auf schwarze Listen geschrieben wurde, ist relativ hoch. Satz war komplizierter.
Im Prinzip merken sich die E-Mail-Server draußen irgendwann, Cloud Computing von Amazon zum Beispiel, da kommt häufig Spam raus. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen neuen E-Mail-Rechner, also einen E-Mail-Server aufsetze, in der Amazon-Wolke und dann damit anfange, wilde E-Mails zu verschicken, könnte das viele Leute sagen, du bist doch einer von den Spammers. Kommt man irgendwie wieder raus, oder ist es dann einfach gelaufen?
Das ist echt schwer daraus zu kommen. Also im konkreten Fall Amazon ist der einfachste Weg, sich einfach einen neuen Server hochzufahren. Der kriegt eine neue Adresse und das so oft zu machen, bis man einen hat, der nicht mehr hat. Das ist tatsächlich das einfachste Szenario, um da rauszukommen. Aber das ist ja nur quasi der Missbrauch auf unterster Ebene. Das war ja quasi nur das Level, Hacker benutzen das genauso, wie sie in anderen Computer verwenden könnten, um Quatschstammel zu treiben. Darüber gibt es deutlich interessante...
Ich würde gerne noch mal dabei verweilen. Also wenn wir jetzt Spam-Mills, das ist nervig, aber nicht wirklich gefährlich. Wird das denn auch wirklich benutzt für Übernahmeangriffe, um Dinge zu hacken? Kann man damit mit dieser Größe an Rechenleistung, die auf Knopfdruck zur Verfügung steht, noch mehr treiben, außer Spam-Mills zu verschicken?
Genau, darauf wollte ich gerade kommen. Wir kommen ja die ganze Zeit von diesen... Das Passwort heute Abend ist ja Verschlüsselung. Also das heißt, bei diesen ganzen Backup-Diensten ging es ja darum, die Frage, wenn meine Daten sicher verschlüsselt sind, dann könnte man dem vertrauen. Nun ist ja ein Problem dieser Verschlüsselung. Man liest das ab und zu in der Zeitung. Die Vergleiche sind immer, um diese Datei zu knacken, um diesen Schlüssel zu knacken, müsste ein Computer so und so lange rechnen. Also beispielsweise 500 Jahre. Bis heute war jedem klar, na gut, keiner lässt seinen Computer 500 Jahre laufen, um diesen Schlüssel zu knacken. Und das stimmt natürlich. Trotzdem hab ich in der Cloud heute die Möglichkeit, einfach 5000 Computer zu betreiben. Und 5000 Computer brauchen dann natürlich nur noch ein Zehnteljahr, um diesen Schlüssel zu hacken. Und es gibt den ersten Dienst, der tatsächlich in der Cloud aktiv ist. Es gibt auf Amazon Web Services, ich weiß nicht, ob es sie immer noch gibt, aber einen Dienst, die anbieten, WPA-Schlüssel zu knacken. Genau. WPA gilt bislang als relativ sicher. Web ist quasi erschlagend gehackt. WPA gilt bislang noch als relativ sicher. Es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass die immense, also das ist ja egal, wie der Angriff läuft, sie kriegen diese Dinge mit einer relativ hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit geknackt. Ich glaube, es kostet 20 Dollar. Die muss man einfach überweisen und dann kann man einen WPA-Schlüssel knacken.
Wie funktioniert das? Man muss irgendwie ein bisschen wieder abhören, schickt den Traffic dahin oder was?
Genau, man braucht sehr wenige Pakete. Konkretes Angriffsszenario, ich bin in einer Wohnung, ich möchte in das Netzwerk meines Nachbarn einbrechen. Ich muss ein paar Pakete aufzeichnen, die da durch die Luft fliegen, das ist nicht sehr kompliziert. Und dann übersende ich diese Pakete und den Netzwerknamen an den Anbieter, überweise 20 Dollar und kriege, mit gewisser Wahrscheinlichkeit, den Schlüssel zurückgeschickt.
Das ist hochgradig illegal oder darf man das?
Das ist fürchterlich illegal.
Aber das macht den Betreibern von diesem Angebot nichts aus?
Deshalb bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es die noch gibt oder nicht.
Aber die gab es auf jeden Fall. Grundsätzlich einen Schlüssel zu knacken, ist jetzt erstmal nichts illegales. Der Anbieter kann auch sagen, schickt uns eine Datei und wir knacken die. Aber wir wissen natürlich nicht, dass es für das WPA Netzwerk von deinem Nachbarn ist. Ich schicke das hin und sage, ich habe den Schlüssel zu meinem eigenen WLAN vergessen. Könnt ihr den für mich rausfinden?
Ich glaube der professionelle Begriff dafür ist Password Recovery.
Also gibt es auch für ZIP-Files, für Passwortgeschützte, PDFs, für Word-Dokumenten und weiß nicht was alles. Und ich glaube, das gibt so einen Anbieter aus Osteuropa. Und ich vermute mal, dass der mittlerweile auch diesen Weg in die Cloud gegangen ist. Also es gibt da auch durchaus viele Szenarien, man könnte alles Mögliche an Verschlüsselung damit auch brechen. Das muss jetzt nicht der WPA-Schlüssel sein. Also das, was Nico auch schon gesagt hat, wie die IT-Leute sagen, sowas skaliert ganz gut. Das heißt also, ich kann es wirklich dann einfach in die Breite skalieren, sagen, okay, ich werfte halt jetzt nicht einen Rechner fünf Jahre, sondern einfach 5000 Rechner drauf. Und gated spielt jetzt erstmal auch keine Rolle. Und wahrscheinlich, wenn der Schlüssel dann auch irgendwie in der Woche geknackt ist, dann war es das gated ja noch wert.
Um es einmal noch zu sagen, weil es mir am Herzen liegt, also obedarf der Tatsache, ob das Knacken selber legal oder illegal ist, in das Netzwerk des Nachbarn einzubrechen, ist natürlich trotzdem auch gerade illegal.
Das wollte ich an dieser Stelle hören. Wenn es denn verschlüsselt ist und... Nur um darauf noch mal hinzuweisen. Dingens, jetzt haben wir so viele Rechner, jetzt bin ich ganz wirr im Kopf. Verschlüsselung, wenn man, also WPA funktioniert ist, wenn man irgendwie ein paar tausend Rechner raufwürfen, geht es halt sehr schnell. Gibt es denn eine Verschlüsselungsart, die dagegen immun ist? Also sagen die auch bei 5000 Rechnern sagt, den Finger zeigt und sagt nee? Also was ist mit PGP zum Beispiel? Oder GPG? Da sagen die am halb viersten. Na ja, es kommt auf die Verschlüsselung drauf an, die da verwendet wird. Und gut, man kann natürlich auch so Sachen machen wie noch ausprobieren und sowas. Das ist jetzt schwer zu sagen. Also weil natürlich auch die Leistung der Cloud wird ja auch immer größer. Und insofern wird die Sache denn nur teurer, aber dauert nicht länger. Also das ist, so kann man dann halt auch sagen. Hey, super beruhigend. Ja klar, also wenn Geld keine Rolle spielt, dann ziehe ich das Ganze einfach in die Breite und sag jetzt Rechner nicht mehr 10 Rechner, sondern 10.000 Rechner. Einfach alles, was Amazon und alle anderen Anbieter anzubieten hat. Wir nehmen alles. Wie teuer das wohl wäre. Einmal die ganze Rechenleistung aller Cloud Computer. So viel Kohle haben wir aber auf jeden Fall nicht, denke ich. Das kann man also für Unsinn, gibt es noch mehr Unsinn, die man damit treiben kann? Na ja, wenn man einen eigenen Server betreibt, dann sieht man schon, dass da ziemlich viele Angriffsversuche zumindestens auch von Amazon oder von anderen Cloud-Diensten auch ausgehen. Das heißt also, da wird dann probiert, nach fehlerhaften Softwareversionen auf dem Server zu suchen. Also man sieht es dann in irgendwelchen URLs, die man im Blog hat, irgendwelche Datenbank-Administrator-Geschichten oder irgendwelche anderen Zugänge, irgendwelche bekannten Sicherheitslücken im Content-Management-System von der Webseite. Es wird nach Passwörtern oder nach Zugängen mit zu einfachen Passwörtern gesucht, wo dann einfach gescannt wird, also einfach wild drauf los und wir gucken mal, ob irgendwo was gefunden wird. Und sowas wird tatsächlich auch ganz viel von diesen Cloud-Servern mittlerweile gemacht, dass man eigentlich, wenn man einen eigenen Server betreibt, mittlerweile diese IP-Adressen, diese Bereiche eigentlich sperren kann, weil da ist jetzt auch nicht so furchtbar viel Sinnvolles zu erwarten. Was ich mich jetzt frage ist, es ist also nicht teuer, also nicht derbeteuer, sich so ein Ding zu mieten. Das heißt, es lohnt sich wahrscheinlich ziemlich schnell. Gibt es da irgendwelche Statistiken? Habt ihr da irgendwas am Kopf, wo man sagen kann, das lohnt sich für die Leute, die damit Schindeludertreiben, einfach weil sie dann viel mehr Geld mit einnehmen, als so eine Cloud zu mieten kostet? Gibt es da Zahlen?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass die veröffentlicht werden.
Ja, aber es gibt ja meistens sozusagen Schätzungen irgendwie.
Nein, ich habe keine Schätzungen.
Nein, es kommt auch immer noch auf Anweisungen, was dir wert ist, einfach so einen Schlüssel zu knacken. Also für dich ist es wert, in ein bestimmtes WLAN reinzukommen. Die andere Sache ist natürlich, weil ich mir so vorstelle, die Cloud nutze ich und ich muss dafür zahlen, aber allerliebsten wäre es mir doch, ich muss gar nichts dafür zahlen. Ich übernehme einfach eine Cloud, die jemand anders gemietet hat. Wie mache ich das?
Also einmal, um sozusagen an der Stelle noch ein bisschen Werbung zu machen, weil du wolltest ja schon auf die Einbruchsszenarien, das gibt es an der Stelle. Es gibt Cloud-Ambieter, die es anbieten, die den Einstieg umsonst machen. Interessant ist da sicherlich im Moment die Google App Engine. Da kann ich bis zum gewissen Grad, kann ich anfangen, Cloud-Infrastrukturen auszuprobieren und muss dafür nicht bezahlen.
Also in einem Rahmen, der tatsächlich auch was bringt, oder?
Jaja, bis zu einem wahnsinnig hohen Rahmen, kann man sogar sagen. Also das heißt, alle normalen Webseiten kann man dort quasi für umsonst betreiben. Und wenn man nicht gerade eine gigantische Webseite ist, das Problem ist, dass die Entwicklungsoberfläche, auf der man das betreiben muss, nicht sehr üblich ist. Also dort läuft kein normales Blogsystem. Es ist eine Python, es geht zu weit ins Detail. Man muss sich damit auseinandersetzen, aber es ist interessant, damit einmal rumzuspielen und einen sehr innovativen und anderen Ansatz, dieses Cloud Computing anzugehen, worauf du aber schon wieder hinaus wolltest, war natürlich schön kluter.
Jetzt bin ich der Böse hier.
Während wir davor darüber gesprochen haben, wie man mit der Cloud nach außen Mist machen kann, gibt es natürlich noch die interessante Frage, ob es Angriffsszenarien auf die Cloud gibt. Und die gibt es natürlich. Und diese sind auch sehr interessant, weil auf unserem Notizzettel für die heutige Sendung steht...
Hach, halt, halt, halt. Wir hören jetzt eine Musik, dann machen wir Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und dann sagst du, wie das mit den Angriffen auf die Cloud funktioniert.
Denn sie ist wieder da.
Eine Karte für 10 Konzerte. Fettes Brot, Shoutout Lautz und Larue.
Matzen, Jennifer Rostock, Kaija Candela und Gossip. Eine Karte für 10 Konzerte. Nur bei Fritz und nur zu gewinnen.
Immer Montag bis Freitag bei den Radio Fritzen am Nachmittag um 10 nach 3.
Mehr Infos Fritze.
Die Fritz 10 Konzertkarte.
Neues Jahr. Neues Glück. Einen Tag vor der Londoner Afghanistan-Konferenz hat der Bundestag über den deutschen Einsatz am Hindukusch diskutiert. Kanzlerin Merkel sagte in einer Regierungserklärung, Ziel sei es, die Verantwortung für das Land Schritt für Schritt in die Hände der Afghanen zu übergeben. SPD-Chef Gabriel forderte einen konkreten Zeitplan für den Abzug der deutschen Truppen ab 2011. Nur dann würden die Sozialdemokraten einem neuen Afghanistan-Mandat zustimmen. In London kommen morgen Vertreter von 70 Ländern zusammen, um über die Zukunft Afghansans zu beraten. Die internationale Gemeinschaft will dem Jemen stärker wirtschaftlich und politisch helfen. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Konferenz in London, an der Vertreter von rund 20 Staaten und Organisatoren wie der Weltbank teilnahmen. Nach Angaben des britischen Außenministers Milliband wurde ein Fünf-Punkte-Plan vereinbart. Er sieht unter anderem Hilfen bei der Grenzsicherung des Jemen und eine Unterstützung durch den Währungsfonds IWF vor. US-Ausministerin Clinton betonte, ein instabiler Jemen sei eine Gefahr für die ganze Region. Das verarmte Land gilt als Rückzugsgebiet für Mitglieder des Terronetzwerkes Al-Qaeda. Soziale Netzwerke wie Facebook oder StudiVZ sollten noch sicherer werden. Das Bundesverbraucherministerium fordert von den Anbietern, dass Daten von vornherein geblockt werden, damit nicht erst die Nutzer aktiv werden müssen. Außerdem sollten nach Meinung des Ministeriums inhaltende Netzwerke komplett wieder gelöscht werden können. Mehrere soziale Netzwerke hatten im letzten Jahr auf eine Abmahnung der Verbraucherzentralen reagiert und versprochen, mehr für den Datenschutz zu tun. Fußball-Zweitliges Union Berlin muss in den nächsten Spielen auf Abwehrspieler Daniel Schulz verzichten. Er hat sich gestern beim Training den Mittelfingern gebrochen und fällt bis zu zehn Wochen aus. Unionssportdirektor Beek sagte, die erneute Verletzung sei bitter für Schulz, weil er vorher noch lange Knieprobleme gehabt hatte. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Cottbus haben wir minus 6 Grad, in Frankfurt sind es minus 5, in Potsdam und Angermünde minus 4, in Neuropie minus 2, in Wittenberge minus 1 und in Berlin um die minus 4 Grad. Nacht ist bewölkt und schenkt euch bis zu 8 cm Neuschnee. Die Tiefsttemperatur liegt bei minus 7 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann ab und zu Schnee und Graubeschauer. Es wird etwas wärmer als heute und das Ganze bei knapp über 0 Grad. A2 in Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Cäsar und Volinen besteht Gefahr durch ein Defekt des Fahrzeuges, das die rechte Spur blockiert. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen 3 Knutetal und Ludwigsfelde West gab es einen Unfall. Hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. A10 östlicher Berliner Ring Richtung 3 Schwanenbeck. Zwischen 3 Spree und Freienbrink gab es einen Unfall. Hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin A100, A111. Hier ist über noch alles zu. Es gibt immer mal wieder Stau und stockenden Verkehr. Fahrt vorsichtig, da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt. Die zwei Sprechstunden mit Nico und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio und Nico von der Firma Schnee von Morgen, nee von gestern, von übermorgen, von wie war es?
Von morgen natürlich.
Schnee von morgen, natürlich war es Schnee von morgen. Und mir Markus Richter, der sozusagen dafür da ist, die beiden Nerds im Zaum zu halten, wenn ich das mal so formulieren darf. Es geht heute um Cloud Computing. Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde und wir wollten noch mal drüber reden, wie man das Cloud Computing hacken kann. Ich will eine von euch beiden noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. Cloud Computing.
Ich will noch einmal das tolle Zitat von dem Notiz-Zettel hier.
Warte, erst noch mal nur für den Fall, das Leute jetzt gerade erst angemacht haben. Cloud Computing ist?
Die ominöse Wolke im Internet. Software-SS-Service, Dienste, die nicht mehr bei mir selber stattfinden, sondern auf einer fremden skalierbaren Infrastruktur.
Wow, wer es nicht verstanden hat, ruft jetzt an. 0331 77 97 110. Es geht also darum, dass ich mir Rechenleistungen im Netz mieten kann und zwar auch in Höhe von mehreren tausend Computern. Und wir haben uns gerade... Und auch Speicherplatz. Speicherplatz, also quasi ganze Maschinen, die aber gar keine wirklichen Maschinen sind, sondern nur so tun, als wären sie Maschinen. Und wir wollten gerade noch darüber sprechen, wie das aussieht. Das könnte man auch sozusagen sich zu Nutze machen. Eigentlich muss man dafür bezahlen, aber wenn ich es irgendwie schaffe, das zu übernehmen, dann muss ich ja nichts dafür bezahlen. Wie geht das? Und wenn ja, wie? Also ich glaube, dass das viel dramatischere Szenario wäre, wenn ich tatsächlich auch von mir aus auch bezahle dafür und also mittendrin sitze in so einer Cloud und dann da anfange, Daten einzusammeln. Und da gibt es durchaus auch Szenarien, die sind im Moment noch theoretisch. Also das heißt, da sitzen jetzt Leute dran und überlegen sich, okay, ich habe einen virtuellen Server, aber in Wirklichkeit ist es ja schon eine echte physikalische Hardware. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt drei Leute so eine virtuelle Maschine gemietet haben, dann heißt es aber, dass diese drei Leute in Wirklichkeit auf einer echten Maschine sind, die aber einfach durch drei geteilt wird. Das heißt also, da wird einfach die Kapazität der Maschine einfach in drei Kuchenstücke aufgeteilt und die teilen die sich. Aber in Wirklichkeit sind die physikalisch, das heißt, sie benutzen irgendwie die gleiche CPU und den gleichen Arbeitsspeicher und es geht irgendwie alles durch die gleichen Datenleitungen durch, die auf der gleichen Platine in diesem Gerät sind. Und die Frage ist, ob es nicht eine Möglichkeit gibt, irgendwie zu schauen, was tun eigentlich die anderen in ihrem virtuellen System. Das ist so die Fragestellung dabei.
Darf ich ihn jetzt endlich sagen?
Jetzt endlich, los!
Der Satz, der auf dem Zettel steht, heißt Hack one, get ten free. Und der beschreibt natürlich diesen Umstand, dass wenn ich einen Einstiegsweg in diese Cloud-Dienste finde, um Benutzerdaten zu knacken oder um irgendwie auf virtuelle Server rauszukommen, dann ist der natürlich reproduzierbar und ermöglicht mir perspektivisch eine Armada von Rechnern zu übernehmen.
Du hast in deinem Beispiel gesagt, was ist die größte Anzahl an virtuellen Maschinen, die ihr mal hochgefahren habt?
Bei uns waren es, glaube ich, 250. Und für den Otto-Normal-User ist es so, dass wenn man mehr als 20 haben will, muss man einmal eine E-Mail schreiben. Dann kriegt man aber auch sofort mehr.
Okay, aber das heißt sozusagen, in dem Moment, wo bei eurer einen Maschine jemand ein Loch gefunden hätte, hätte er damit auch die restlichen 250 am Start gehabt.
Hätte er ein Loch gefunden, hätte er alle übernehmen können.
Also der Trick dabei ist, dass du nicht in dieser einen speziellen Maschinenloch findest, sondern generell in diesem ganzen System, was diese virtuellen Maschinen eigentlich verwaltet. Also das ist das sogenannte Host-System. Also man unterscheidet bei diesem virtuellen Computing in der Regel zwischen Host-System und Gast-System. Also ein Host ist also das, was ursprünglich auf diesem Computer läuft. Das ist also eigentlich ein System, was nichts anderes macht, als diese virtuellen Maschinen hoch und runter zu fahren. Und das Gast-System, das sozusagen nistet sich als Gast ein, das ist also dein System, was du mietest da drauf. Und der Trick dabei ist jetzt nicht, dieses Gast-System zu knacken, sondern das Host-System. Also das System, das wirklich unten drunter steckt. Und wenn du in diesem Haus bist, kannst du natürlich auch in diese ganzen Gast-Systeme irgendwie reinschauen. Das heißt, es ist nicht nur so, dass ich dann die ganze Rechenleistung des Host-Systems für mich habe, sondern ich kann auch tatsächlich gucken, was machen die Einzelnen? In der Regel ist das sogar die spannende Information. Also ich meine, Rechenleistung kann man halt irgendwie mieten, da weißt du, das kostet 10 Cent pro Stunde. Aber du willst ja eigentlich wissen, was tun die da eigentlich. Also welche Kreditkartendaten werden da gerade verarbeitet? Welche privaten Facebook-Profile werden da gerade verarbeitet? Halt die ganzen spannenden Informationen. Welche E-Mails liegen da? Das heißt, du willst sowohl einerseits schauen, was tun die da? Das heißt, was geht gerade durch diesen virtuellen Prozessor durch? Andererseits willst du auch wissen, was ist auf den virtuellen Festplatten gelagert? Und das ist, ich will nicht sagen, dass es jetzt einfacher ist als bei der klassischen Infrastruktur, aber es ist natürlich schon sehr verlockend, wenn die Sachen alle im Internet sind. Sie sind da erreichbar. Ich kann mich möglicherweise mit einer falschen Identität anmelden. Es ist eine ziemliche Anonymität da, was diesen Anbieter angeht. Und wenn ich dann erst mal auf diesen Kissen bin, kann ich natürlich auch anfangen, da ein bisschen Forschung zu betreiben. Forschung betreiben? Du sagst das gerade schon. Da sitzen gerade Leute dran, um rauszugucken, ob es funktioniert. Gab es da schon Fälle, von denen man weiß? Nee, also die werden auch ziemlich durch die Medien gegangen, wenn da tatsächlich was ist. Es gibt auf jeden Fall Ansätze. Das ist natürlich alles noch ein bisschen, teilweise sehr theoretisch, sehr wissenschaftlich. Man geht auf verschiedene Wege ran. Ich würde aber nicht ausschließen, dass da innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre irgendwas passiert, was das Konzept vielleicht sogar grundsätzlich in Frage stellt. Das ist durchaus denkbar. Es wird sozusagen wie bei der Playstation 3, wo heute der Proof of Concept, der als exploit, wie es so schön heißt, rausgekommen ist. Also man kann die theoretisch hacken, müsst jetzt nur noch jemand so machen, das komfortabel ist. Danach wird bei Cloud Computing noch gesucht nach dem ersten großen Gau. Genau, und man hofft natürlich, dass es denn auch publik wird, wenn es jemand schafft. Der wirklich große Gau ist natürlich, dass es jemand schafft, und es nicht publik wird, sondern es halt einfach so gemacht wird. Und diese Informationen darüber auch in irgendwelchen Kreisen für ziemlich viel Geld gehandelt wird. Das wäre natürlich dann schon ziemlich dramatisch.
Also ich hoffe, dass es keiner schafft.
Ja, aber wie wahrscheinlich ist das, dass es keiner schafft? Tja, da müssen wir jetzt mal in die Glaskugel gucken.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, also die Angriffszenarien, die ich bislang gelesen habe, die sind interessant, aber wie ich finde, bislang noch nicht bedrohlich. Es geht im Kern darum, zuerst eine virtuelle Maschine zu starten, die auf dem gleichen System läuft, wie der, den ich angreifen will. Ein Angriffszenario hat ja irgendwie ein Ziel. Also das heißt, erstmal will ich ja nicht einfach nur beliebig...
Ah, und ich bin der Böse. Ich war nur davon ausgegangen, dass ich mir möglichst billig Rechenleistungen besorgen möchte. Du allerdings, ja?
Sondern das für den Bösen interessante Angriffszenario ist natürlich, wenn ich von jemandem weiß, dass er auf der Cloud läuft, muss ich erstmal in die Nähe seines Hostsystems kommen, physikalisch. Möchte man normal ja an, das geht nicht, weil ich sozusagen gar nicht beeinflussen kann, wie dieser Computer startet. Da gibt es aber inzwischen einen ganz guten Ansatz, also gut, um das zu schaffen. Also um eine Maschine zu starten, die auf der gleichen Infrastruktur läuft, wie das Ziel. Und dann laufen die Angriffszenarien darüber, erstmal überhaupt Netzwerk-Traffic, der auf dem zweiten virtuellen System neben mir liegt, mitzuhören. Und da gibt es inzwischen so eine Art Proof-of-Konzept. Wobei die Virtualisierer, die angesetzt werden, auch sehr unterschiedlich sind. Also Amazon setzt auf Xen, das ist ein Open-Source-Projekt. Mehrere andere setzen auf VM-Ware. Und es gibt einfach auch unterschiedliche Systeme, in dieser Art zu virtualisieren.
Wie erreicht man das, dass man auf demselben System landet, wie der, den ich jetzt ausschnüffeln will?
Übertreint error. Also die Attacke geht einfach tatsächlich darüber, dass man sagt, ich fahre mir ganz viele Rechner hoch, und dann haben sie einen Test geschrieben, wie ich sehr zuverlässig sagen kann, ob ich neben dem anderen liege. Ich glaube, es funktioniert über Hardware-UIDs, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist vielleicht nochmal eine ganz andere Sache, die auch noch extrem wichtig ist. Wir haben ja bisher über Sachen gesprochen, oder Nico setzt jetzt diese Virtualisierung ein, um Sachen darauf zu berechnen, die wahrscheinlich sowieso früher oder später im Internet landen, also die relativ öffentlich sind. Problematisch wird es natürlich für Firmen, die da auch private Daten oder nicht öffentliche Daten dann in diese Cloud auslagern wollen. Also klassischer Fall wäre jetzt ein Versicherungskonzern, das ganze IT bei uns im Keller verbraucht nur Strom, und irgendwie haben wir keine Lust mehr. Wir lagern uns jetzt in die Cloud, und wir mieten jetzt einfach ein paar virtuelle Server. Und dann haben wir natürlich ganz neue Probleme, was jetzt einmal diese rechtliche Situation angeht. Weil natürlich diese Cloud, haben wir ja gesagt, ist eine ganz diffuse Sache. Das heißt, wir wissen möglicherweise gar nicht mehr, in welchem Land diese Server stehen. Stehen sie in Deutschland, stehen sie irgendwo in der EU, in Europa, stehen sie in den USA, in Asien, China vielleicht. Das ist alles durchaus denkbar mit so einer Cloud. Und da haben wir das Problem, dass ich als Firma dann eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich Herr über diese Daten bin. Das heißt, die liegen dann irgendwo, und ich hab wahrscheinlich auch das Versprechen von dem Anbieter, dass niemand anderes auf diese Daten zugreift. Letztendlich gibt es natürlich aber nie eine Garantie, dass zum Beispiel diese Festplatten irgendwann mal, wenn sie dann, sag ich mal, verbraucht sind, oder nach einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren, wenn sie gelaufen sind, dass die irgendwann einfach rausgezogen werden im laufenden Betrieb und dann irgendwo der Entsorgung zugeführt werden. Das heißt, da gibt es dann Leute, die dann irgendwie gerne diese Festplatten entgegennehmen und gucken, was man vielleicht von diesen Daten noch runterkratzen könnte. Und das ist natürlich schon ein Szenario, wenn ich als Firma wirklich heikle, sensible Daten verarbeite, aber eigentlich nicht mehr dieses System vollständig unter Kontrolle habe. Dann muss ich einfach auch schauen, welche gesetzlichen Regelungen gelten. Kann ich das als Firma überhaupt machen, meine IT auslagern, irgendwo anders hin in eine Cloud? Das heißt, ich muss also irgendwie auch schauen, ein gewisses Vertragsverhältnis haben. Ich muss gucken, ob es mir die Regelungen nach dem deutschen Datenschutzgesetz überhaupt erlauben, diese Sachen einfach so rauszugeben. Gibt es eine vertragliche Vereinbarung mit dem Anbieter? Bei vielen wichtigen Daten in Deutschland ist es so, dass sie also nicht aus der EU rausgehen dürfen. Also ich muss dann wirklich auch einen Anbieter nehmen, der mir garantiert, dass diese Sachen in der EU bleiben, weil man einfach sagt, in der EU gibt es einigermaßen halbwegs zuverlässige Datenschutzstandards. In der USA sind diese Datenschutzstandards möglicherweise nicht mehr gegeben. Und dann ist noch die Frage, gibt es denn vielleicht irgendwelche Geheimdienste oder Ermittlungsbehörden, die sagen, ja, wir wollen jetzt aber wirklich mal darauf gucken. Dann habe ich natürlich bei uns in Deutschland oder in der EU eine ganz andere rechtliche Möglichkeit dagegen vorzugehen, in den USA oder China, Israel oder sowas. Wir wollen jetzt eine Festplatte haben, es gibt gar keine Diskussion. Und dann habe ich als Firma, die für diese Daten eigentlich verantwortlich ist, natürlich auch kaum noch eine Handhabe dagegen. Und dann sind diese Daten schon irgendwie weg oder sind dann halt irgendwo anders. Das heißt also, wenn ich selber so eine Firma gründen will, dann sollte ich mal gefälligst gucken, wo das dann hingeht. Wenn ich so einen Service nutzen will tatsächlich, kann ich das denn als User irgendwie rausfinden, wenn ich jetzt so eine Firma gebe. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal wissen, was für eine Infrastruktur die nutzt. Gibt es da Quellen? Kann man das selber irgendwo nachgucken, wo deren Server dann letztendlich stehen? Nee, das ist schwierig. Also wenn der Anbieter da nicht ganz konkret antwortet, dann habe ich eigentlich kaum einen Weg, das rauszufinden. Also dann müsste ich da höchstens auch auf die Datenschutzbehörden vertrauen. Also wenn sich ein Anbieter weigert zu sagen, wo er seine Server zu stehen hat oder ob er sie vielleicht virtualisiert hat, dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, mal auch den Datenschutzbeauftragten anzusprechen. Also die Firma, die macht hier irgendwie so ein Geheimnis daraus. Wollen Sie vielleicht mal nachschauen gehen? Dann kann der natürlich mal zu der Firma gehen, sagen, wo ist denn hier euer Server? Die will ich jetzt gerne mal sehen. Die sind in der Cloud. Was gibt es denn da für Verträge? Wo stehen die denn? Welche Sicherheitsvorkehrungen habt ihr getroffen? Und möglicherweise ist dann sogar auch ein Bußgeld fällig für die Firma. Das kann auch passieren. Wer hat diese Daten dann unüberlegt irgendwo hin auslagert in die Cloud und sich da auch keine Gedanken über irgendwelche juristischen Beschränkungen gemacht hat? Das ist aber sozusagen eher das große Schutz für den alltäglichen Gebrauch nicht wirklich irgendwie praktikabel. Also ich will ja nicht jedes Mal, wenn ich mich irgendwo auf eine Webseite anmelde, zum Datenschutzbeauftragten gehen. Das ist dann quasi schon eher Aktivismus als tatsächlich praktikabel. Aber da muss man jetzt leben. Wie ist es denn überhaupt, du hast das vorhin schon mal die Glaskugel erwähnt, wo geht das jetzt hin? Was kommt als nächstes mit dem Cloud Computing? Wird das so weitergehen, dass du einfach sagen immer mehr, immer besser im Netz? Oder wird es dann mal einen Umschwung geben? Gibt es da schon was abzusehen? Also ich denke, dass gerade bei der Verfügbarkeit wird es für Firmen spannend. Also auch wirklich für ernsthafte Anwendungen. Also werde ich wirklich als Firma auf diese Systeme angewiesen bin, dass sie da sind, dass sie funktionieren, dass sie auch mit einer gewissen Performance arbeiten. Das heißt, dass ich einfach eine bestimmte Rechenleistung ganz sicher zur Verfügung habe. Das kann ich eigentlich nur machen, wenn ich dieses Rechenzentrum selbst betreibe oder wenn ich die Server selbst betreibe und wirklich im Keller vor mir zu stehen habe. Also ich bin da sehr skeptisch, was wirklich, ich sag mal, unternehmenskritische Anwendungen angeht. Also ich würde mir vielleicht widersprechen. Aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich absolut 100 Prozent garantieren muss, also wie so Sachen wie jetzt hier im Rundfunk, im Fernsehen, das ist ein klassischer Fall, wo einfach auch Kraftwerke einfach ganz konservativ sagen, also da darf es keinen Ausfall geben, da gibt es keine Ausrede, sondern es muss einfach funktionieren. Punkt. Und das sind einfach klassische Sachen, die kann ich nicht in die Cloud geben. Und ich denke mal, dass es möglicherweise auch, wenn der Trend weiter anhält und wenn man Sachen in die Cloud geht, die Anbieter aber nicht entsprechend nachrüsten und aufstocken, dann wird es da auch vielleicht zu einem Engpass geben, was dann vielleicht auch wieder Leute dazu bewegen könnte, nachzudenken, ob das jetzt eine richtige Entscheidung war. Wir hatten was Ähnliches beim Outsourcing, es war auch eine große Welle vor ein paar Jahren, alles nach Indien, alles nach Indien. Und jetzt merken die Firmen, aber das bringt eigentlich nicht so viel und jetzt geht auch ganz wieder viel zurück davon. Es war auch so ein typischer Hype. Ja, es ist jetzt wirklich ein Glaskugelschauen. Wahrscheinlich wird sich diese Cloud Computing-Geschichte halten, weil diese Virtualisierungslösungen funktionieren alle auch schon recht gut, von ein paar Kleinigkeiten abgesehen. Und möglicherweise ist es ja auch ein Weg und ein Mittel, um den wachsenden Stromverbrauch irgendwie einigermaßen in Grenzen zu kriegen, der durch die IT entsteht. Cloud Computing kann man nicht für kritische Strukturen benutzen. Das hört sich für mich an, wie wenn ich eine Firma neu grinde, dann mach ich erst mal Cloud Computing, weil es billig ist. Wenn da Kram wirklich nicht funktionieren muss, dann sollte ich danach denken, mir die Server wieder hinzustellen. Wenn ich auch absehen kann, dass der Service auch gut läuft und ich die Server auch wirklich brauche. Und dann vielleicht nochmal für Last-Spitzen, um wirklich irgendwelche kurzzeitigen Sachen abzufackeln, eine Werbekampagne oder sowas, dann kann ich ja immer noch welche dazu nehmen. Das ist, es scheint mir ziemlich viel Technik zu sein, dass man sagt, naja, funktioniert irgendwie, kann man benutzen, aber wenn es kritisch wird, dann lieber selber machen. Könnte man das so zusammenfassen, dein Blick auf Cloud Computing? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe einfach keine Garantie, dass es wirklich 100% funktioniert. Das habe ich jetzt bei eigenen Server nicht, aber da kann ich wenigstens den... Selber schuld sein... .denn mich selber schuld, genau.
Also ich würde dir gerne einmal die Gegenposition ergreifen. Also um selber einmal die Glaskugel reinzublicken. Ich glaube, dass wir wirklich erwarten eine sehr strenge Diskussion, wo es um Datensicherheit, wo es um Datenschutz geht, wo es um diese Diskussion geht. Meine Fotos liegen auf Flickr, meine Videos liegen auf YouTube, meine Identität im weitesten Sinne liegt auf Facebook, meine täglichen Status-Updates liegen irgendwie auf Twitter. Was bedeutet das mit diesen Daten? Was bedeutet Privatsphäre da drin? Das werden wir erwarten, das wird eine Bremse sein. Ich glaube, dass es für Unternehmen in Zukunft Cloud Computing quasi unumgänglich ist. Ich glaube, dass alle dorthin wechseln werden. Ich glaube, dass dieser Zuverlässigkeitsgedanke heute schon, wenn man einfach unter den Strich schaut und guckt, welche Infrastruktur einfach verlässlicher ist, dann haben sich die großen Cloud Computing Dienste einfach als wahnsinnig schlagkräftig herausgestellt. In solchen Fällen wie Kraftwerken, unternehmenskritische Daten setzt sich inzwischen der Trend durch, das auch im Cloud Computing zu machen, aber die Cloud selber zu betreiben. Also das heißt zu sagen, ich nutze nicht diese Infrastruktur, die auf Servern irgendwo auf der Welt steht. Wenn ich eine große deutsche Bank bin, dann will ich meine Kundendaten nicht auf der Welt verstreut, auf Festplatten haben, die ich nicht in der Kontrolle habe. Aber ich möchte dieses System nutzen, die Art und Weise, wie die Computer miteinander kommunizieren, diese Art und Weise der Virtualisierung. Und ich wäre blöd, mir so ein System nicht selber aufzusetzen. Das heißt, ich glaube, die Tage, wo der Computer physisch im Rack drin steht und nur diese eine Aufgabe hat, diesen glaube ich gezählt.
Okay, das heißt, man kann das weiter nutzen. Aber wie gesagt, bei kritischen Sachen sollte man vorsichtig sein. Was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, ich bin ja eher so ein, kann man sagen, Aushilfsnörd. Ich betreibe halt, ich habe auch so selber Web-Space und mache das auch selber. Wann wird das oder ab wann lohnt es sich, dass ich selber eingehe und sage so, ich möchte jetzt so eine kleine Cloud-Instanz für mich haben? Dann nimmst du einfach einen Taschenrechner und guckst mal nach, was dich dieser klassische Web-Space kostet und guckst nach, was sich so eine Cloud-Instanz kostet im Monat. Aber Cloud und sagen heißt auf jeden Fall, ich muss mich selber kümmern. Also da kriege ich quasi so eine Maschine angeboten, die muss ich dann selber bestücken. Richtig, du fängst wirklich mit einer leeren Festplatte an, virtuellen Festplatte. Kannst du denn in der Regel eine Installations-CD aussuchen, ob du da jetzt ein Linux oder ein Windows-System drauf haben willst. Und dann spielst du das da ein, fängst mit einem leeren System an und musst dann ganz klassisch erstmal die Software installieren, Passwörter einrichten, User einrichten und sowas. Es gibt ja ganz gute fertigen Sachen. Also du kannst sagen, du kannst irgendwie einen Drupal-CMS, einen Content-Management-System haben oder willst du irgendwie einen Video-Server haben. Das bieten einige der Anbieter mittlerweile fertig an. Das ist ja nur noch... Das ist ein bisschen aber auch teurer, ne? Nö. Also von der Computing-Zeit her ist es das gleiche. Was teilweise ein bisschen teurer ist, ist wenn du Windows-Systeme hast. Was dann einfach daran liegt, dass auch die Lizenzkosten dafür schon drin sind, wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Im Übrigen ein interessantes Cloud-Problem, dass Software-Lizenzen heute ja meist an die Installation oder den Prozessor gebunden sind.
Also das Windows selbst auch schon, ja.
Genau, und die Lizenzgeber tatsächlich schwere Probleme haben, sich an diese Cloud zu gewöhnen und zu sagen, was ist eine Lizenz in Zeitaltern dieser schwammigen Grenzen? Es gibt da neue Lizenzierungsmodelle, also Oracle hat eins draußen, Browser Streaming Server, Adobe. Also es gibt sozusagen Lizenzierungsmodelle dafür, aber es kommt sehr zaghaft.
Hast du da selber schon mal Probleme mit gehabt?
Nee, wir haben tatsächlich schnell eine Lösung gefunden, aber das hätte ein großes Problem für uns sein können.
Okay, Lizenzierungsprobleme gibt es also auch noch. Wir haben ziemlich viel gelernt heute über Cloud Computing hier im Chaos Radio auf Ritz, Frank Rosengard und Nico... Oh Gott, jetzt hab ich den Nachnamen vergessen. Nico Longolius. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Noch letzte Hörer, sowas wie immer Backups machen. Herrgott, zum Beispiel auch von meiner Sprechfähigkeit. Wollt ihr da noch was loswerden? Also eine gute Idee ist ein Backup, einfach auf nächstes Jahr eine Festplatte zu machen, vielleicht sogar zu verschlüsseln und irgendwie einem guten Kumpel in die Hand zu drücken, dass es aus der Wohnung raus ist.
Für die meisten User ist der Satz, einen Backup haben ist schon toll. Ich glaube, die meisten User da draußen haben nach gar keins. Eins ist schon verdammt gut.
Einen Backup sollt ihr also jedenfalls haben. Das gilt auch nach zwei Stunden Cloud Computing im Chaos Radio auf Ritz. Und immer gut das Internet in Schuss halten, sonst bringt die Cloud nichts. Das stimmt. Und hier kommen jetzt, ich hoffe, sie haben es gut durch die Cloud da draußen geschafft, Smith und Smart, die euch im Night Flight mit Mash-Ups erfreuen werden. Wahrscheinlich blutet euch danach das Ohr, aber es lohnt sich. Hier gibt es wie immer zum Abschluss vom Chaosradio von Trekkie Birthday. Web-Side.